[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
have we mentioned there's also a million
dollars at stake the total pot is a
million dollars no that it's not a typo
the prizes are unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remain what a move by Timur it's
over he's gonna lift to tell the tale
and that is enough to take victory in
this Armageddon game Dan yet
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real oh my God massive
congratulations to Sam Savion a trip to
the cgc finals and a clean shot at the
largest first place prize of the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 16. who
will take the next step to Toronto
welcome to the 2022 chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave I'm
Grand Master Robert Hess and it's the
king of Gotham International Master Levy
Rosman Levy another great day here at
the cgc yes it is and I just learned
that I have a new nickname Robert I
guess you were saving that up for the
hour call that we have before we go live
for these shows I'm very excited it's
been a tremendous amount of fun watching
64 players now down to not quite 16
because we already had a couple of
eliminations what is it something like
12 now but today we have a super
exciting lineup of games and matchups
for you as it's going to be the one seed
in the two seed in both of the
head-to-heads and I think we're about to
go to a full screen bracket to show you
what's been going on thus far Robert
yeah it's super excited where we are and
as we get into the brackets dive into
the details we do want to give a quick
shout out to our friends at Brave who
will take us through Bruce presenting
sponsor for the rest of the cgc
including all the way into Toronto so
we're excited to have Brave with us and
as they join us here in the bracket we
see that as Levy mentioned we do not
have all 16 players remaining in this
knockout portion levonne Ronin Wesley
SOB made their way through yesterday but
today we're at the top of the bracket
Hikaru Nakamura Leonardo Dominguez as
well as they're the bottom left five
minute karwana Dimitri on draken
exactly and it's sort of a dream come
true in the sense that when you get
eight players into a group you see them
one two three four five six seven eight
and sometimes you have upsets on the
right side of your screen in fact you
have a few upsets in some of those
groups you do have some number one seeds
Moving on but that is really what you
are looking for is the person who is
touted to win a group of eight actually
going to emerge in the final and today
the answer to that question is yes and
number one will be taking on number two
yeah the top heavy tournament that we
have here will continue but we do want
to remind everybody of yesterday's
results because two players are have
already punched their tickets through
Toronto two more will join them that was
Wesley so he escaped Jeffrey Zhang
barely in the Armageddon they you know
Jeffrey Zhang was almost had him could
not quite win the game and Wesley held
on and then levonne aronian Levy he's
looking as good as anyone in this field
he absolutely is you see yesterday we
had two completely different story lines
we saw Sam Savion taking some of the
momentum that he brought in with the win
against mvl and when you beat a guy
who's in the top ten and really touted
as a beast in Rapid and Blitz
everybody starts looking like all right
when is the Cinderella story gonna end
or are you going to ride this wave to
the live final obviously in in Toronto
and unfortunately he couldn't quite
continue the run and Levon Dominic and
he just said all right well I'm the one
seed for a reason but on the flip side
you had an absolute barn burner
heavyweight matchup where Jeffrey Zhang
fought back from uh a significant
deficit and won enforcing Armageddon and
was so close Robert he was just so close
inches away from making it Toronto but
unfortunately came up short if we can
have the same level of drama today that
we had yesterday I'm all for it for sure
and for some the clock strikes midnight
as you bring up our remaining
contestants in this knockout Tournament
of course we know Pavel pankratov Alexi
serrana those are higher Seas or players
that might not have been expected to
make their way through to the round of
16. but as we look here and we will see
who else punches their way to Toronto in
addition to Wesley and Lavon it's all
about Nakamura Dominguez and car one on
draken today
yes it is Wesley like we just saw had a
nail-biting experience but he awaits the
winner uh of caruana versus andraken uh
which will obviously lead into the next
round he sits there happily take it well
I don't be happily took care of business
yesterday I think it was a more of a
relief and yes Hikaru obviously the top
seed the dominant man uh today
definitely the best rapid player of the
four that we will have for you for the
audience but um we'll see that's the
amazing thing we can't just predict
Things based on seating they actually
have to play it out and I think we have
a preview right we're going to a preview
of the of the specific matchups for sure
look at these four players on screen in
front of you with the All-American Derby
one seed Hikaru Nakamura taking on
Leonard Dominguez the two seed in that
side of things and then Fabiano caruana
against Dimitri on draken I mean calling
on Drake in a two seed feels like it's a
really not giving him the benefit of his
skill set but these two matchups Levy I
think that everybody has been waiting
for them in the round of 16.
absolutely and they're very different
they're different in the sense that
Hikaru and Lanier play all the time
they've played in classical rapid
they've played at St Louis just a few
weeks ago but karawana and and Drake and
except for their online games have maybe
played each other just the limited
amount of times I'm I'm not sure where
they could even possibly meet they are
at the upper echelon of the game but
generally unless you're invited to a
tournament you're not really going to
see these two going at it so this is the
beauty of the CJC is that if you put two
of them in a group that is what happens
they emerge out of uh the darkness that
is a a group of eight as the one and two
seed and they're very interesting
stylistically right Robert because I
feel like Dimitri is much more inclined
to mix it up I feel like Fabiano is a
Cutting Edge theoretician he will maybe
be looking to put away Dimitri just
straight out of some sort of preparation
that he that he finds could be a
weakness I don't know you you probably
know a little bit more about the piano
than me and you've seen a bit more of
Dimitri's games what do you expect for
today yeah Dimitri is the ultimate
grinder and we see the head-to-head
comparison this does not surprise me
they are tied in classical they are tied
in Rapid but Levy I feel like that last
bullet point there on Drake and beating
car on two nothing in the RCC a bit
misleading because five minute lost the
second game because his internet
disconnected in a completely winning
position that is indeed tragic yes that
should be one one that is the struggle
of playing games online and I kinda
look back to that classical score I I
mentioned that I don't think they've
played many games against each other
these guys are probably both about 30
and they've played five games of
classical chess against each other over
the course of their careers they just
don't find themselves in similar events
and to be honest you go back in their
history I don't know where those games
are it's not a steal maybe somewhere
maybe a grand Swiss and a lot of draws
right so the truth is Robert I feel like
we don't know anything about this
matchup this is like a total toss-up and
I I have no idea what to expect really
that's the what makes this super
exciting and in many ways Dimitri on
Drake is the unsung hero of online chess
the guy is winning title Tuesdays left
and right he meets at the final the
grand final of the rapid Chess
Championship but before ultimately being
eliminated by janapamishi but today's
big matchup the one that is starting
first is between Hikaru Nakamura and
lenier Dominguez and as we look at this
head to head look at how many draws they
have in classical and how few draws they
have in Rapid
linear is a very solid player and In
classical chess that is really an
important asset to have as a skill he's
been consistently 27 50 27 60 2770 and
it kind of is not super surprising
because I feel like if they played a lot
more games when Hikaru was a bit younger
in his career throwing out Kings Indians
at everybody then maybe there would be
more wins and losses but it kind of
makes sense because I think Hikaru
toward well I don't want to say the end
of his classical career but he obviously
more recently has played a lot more
online and more rapid and Blitz he's
been a bit more of a of a solid player
kind of having what they call maybe a
professional repertoire with some of
these Queens Gambit declines but we saw
that in their rapid hit the head the
eight wins four four losses one draw
there are almost no draws and that's
what makes this intriguing because every
time Hikaru plays Lanier I pay attention
Hikaru might have a bit more of a
provocative style and here is Rock Solid
but when you get them into faster and
faster time controls Hikaru definitely
has an advantage and we'll see what
happens today
for sure but I know Leonard Dominguez is
taking online play more seriously and
well we want to remind everybody of
their votes our community got involved
before the event began made their
predictions and I just have to say
outright Levy these predictions here
ridiculous yeah ridiculous I think if
Lanier had a twitch Channel this would
be like 75-25 at least I think he would
get five times as many votes I just
think that people expect Hikaru to win
and back when we did the bracket
analysis bracket preview with Danny and
with nariditski I kind of said the same
thing and you put Hikaru in a group
you're like all right it'll take care of
business I'm just gonna go over here you
really don't have to monitor him but
Lanier is a perfect adversary for being
a second seed he's been amazing in this
event he took care of Eric Hansen quite
convincingly and if he shows up today
and plays that style it neutralizes
Hikaru and doesn't get too low on time
and I don't see a reason why he can't be
the one going to Toronto but obviously
95.5 is a bit insane yes and same 78 for
carwana that felt like a lot but here we
see uh to remind everybody of what the
format is because you said when a car
plays he's the favorite but this is an
event with a 15 minute plus two second
increment so it's not just bullet chess
Blitz chess it takes a while to get down
to time travel and Leonard Dominguez is
extremely well prepared he is not going
to go down in any game without a
tremendous fight yeah five percent is
crazy like I I five percent you can
maybe bring in the qualifying round or
something along those lines this
wouldn't be the first time that we saw
an upset but yeah just an overview of
the format once again they play a best
of four first to two and a half out of
those four games does advance and
otherwise they have a bidding system for
the Armageddon as we look at Hikaru and
Lanier you would not think that they are
both about to start a very intense rapid
game linear certainly looks like it but
uh oh there there we go game face and D4
move one from Hikaru will we get a quick
yeah there it is Queen's Gambit accepted
this is a linear specialty it's funny
because I knew you're gonna ask the
question and I knew that linear would
answer it before we even had a chance to
show things linear takes on C4 in the
early stages of the opening very often
when his opponent plays D4 it's a solid
approach he's quickly striking center
with C5 so as we just get this match
underway Levy do we think that linear is
going to have any opening surprises or
as you predicted qga is what is expected
qga is what it is no when you play
Queen's Gambit accepted with black
especially in this line you are very
much a Sitting Duck I mean that's a bit
of a stretch Sitting Duck has a negative
connotation but here we go we see D5
right away from Hikaru and this is this
is one of these moments where and look
at this B5
wow not even taking this Knight on D5
back the sign of what is happening here
well have you ever seen this what is
going on I'm about to click the game
Explorer because I have no idea and this
position apparently at high level games
has only happened a couple of times
there is a knight that has been able to
capture it for many moves the point
everybody is you don't want to take it
you open up the e-file for this Rook on
E1 so that is why lanyard said no and he
was Bishop B4 and Bishop G5
oh my God F6 okay this is crazy they're
just throwing out Theory left and right
and what I was going to say is that when
you play the Queen's gamut accept it
with black you're a Sitting Duck you're
basically waiting for white to instigate
with you and try to pull you either into
25 move deep water or What's Happening
Here Hikaru is trying to take Lanier
completely out of known Theory and the
problem is for him right now Lanier is
obviously very well prepared he's
playing a bunch of absurd looking moves
instantly that's a bad sign
yeah this has been already a fascinating
Battle of opening Theory let's bring up
the analysis board because a lot has
happened we don't want to deprive you of
those little educational tidbits so it
all started around here where after A6
playing on the flank trying to get B5 in
it car decides to strike in the center
and Levy at this point B5 is already a
clear indication that linear has no
interest in taking this Knight on D5
yeah absolutely not first of all Knight
C6 is already a secondary move I believe
uh several moves ago black generally
plays A6 E6 C5 but really Waits a lot of
the time to play the Knight to C6 uh but
uh Lanier did it instantly which I know
he does and I can't say I've ever seen
D5 in that position I've ucd5 frequently
and E4 as well but this is a completely
unique thing I've never seen this in my
life and it makes sense that he wouldn't
take on D5 at any point here because
after you take all of a sudden White's
pieces Venture into the center attack
the Knight The Rook is over there the F7
Pawn is weak and that's why I played C4
cutting the bishop off in the night but
here come tactics and after e takes D5 e
takes D5 this would have been a big
problem with Rook E1 check about to
happen the king strand in the center
foreign
so now probably what's coming next as we
see Hikaru taking a bit of a think is uh
an end game frankly they already have
traded a lot of the pieces and the
question here is is black C4 Pawn an
asset or is it a liability because I'm
going to tell you right now Hikaru
better hope it's a it's a it's a
liability if black is able to trade it
he's gonna get very quick play with the
King going to safety and The Rook coming
in and maybe black is already playing
for some sort of Advantage potentially
and a big issue is that Rook C1 is not
available
at some point so it looks like a very
interesting start to this game uh by
these players Fabiano and andrakin they
will have their game get underway in
just a bit so uh we will try to catch
the start of that game as Hikaru he's
deep in the think tank so here we go we
have these two starting out as well
yeah one funny thing about that uh that
line this move B5
you said it was only really played in
one high level game
and I know we have I know we have this
game up on the screen so I'll I'll save
that but it's chess is so fascinating
how nowadays you can just see data
instantly oh this was played in you know
Budapest 2022 and this day of this month
and this is what the players were
wearing and this is what they had for
breakfast back in the day used to have
to wait for Publications to come out uh
wow we now are this is such a CR Robert
you and I once uh oversaw in our in uh
yeah Vichy versus pan creative in that
first game and that game was as wild as
they get and playing the French against
Fabiano caruana has proven in the past
to be a very bad idea for Grand Masters
I mean Fabiano has won a number of nice
games from the white side of these
positions and in general Levy the double
pawns here on the C file that white is
saddled with for uh pretty much the rest
of the game it's offset with the fact
that white has the pair of Bishops so
what are your thoughts your caracon
flare not a French player but you're
used to these types of structures
I do not understand the win hour for
either color if I have to choose which
side I understand it better for it's
probably for the white side because me
push Pawn me advanced pieces Me Maybe
win I'm really not capable of
understanding what black has to offer
here and I think I have played a few
times in my life that when I were over
the board and I've lost every single
time so basically when I get out of
theory uh you leave me on my own it's a
it's a disaster but andrakin is one of
the other I think Russian players who
plays the French he's a lot of them do I
mean I've even seen yanny pomishi play
it and we see pankrado in this event
playing the French so it's not dead yet
okay maybe in classical We're not gonna
see it as much but in these fast formats
it's super super tricky but Robert just
like officially how do you how do you do
this man you you play the French at
times you know when you're feeling
naughty how do you deal with these
positions I played the French one time
in classical chess and now I
unfortunately have been saddled with a
reputation that includes that in my
repertoire but I think in the French
right we have this very strong Pawn
structure from F7 D5 a pawn chain is
only as strong as its base Pawn White's
base Pawn C3 defended but already D4 is
pressured a bunch of times so oftentimes
this Rook lands on H4 gets into the
attack you start putting pressure on
these pawns on G7 F7 while Black's
position is a bit more clogged so
ideally black plays Bishop D7 castles
and goes for F6 tries to open up the
position more and more but it's easier
said than done
and this is also important because we
haven't analyzed and we don't have that
position on the screen at all which is
the poison pawns really variation when
in the when our black uh allows white to
capture a bunch of Pawns and then
Castle's Queen side this is a much more
positional style winner it's not super
super and now it's going to be
extremely positional game as andraken
completely shuts down the center of the
board it's deadlocked black is going to
try to win on The Queen side and white
is going to try to not lose on the queen
side while also trying to win on the
king side with that big space advantage
and those potentially weak pawns will
and Drake and Castle long will he put
his King in the corner I don't know but
visually speaking I of course slightly
prefer the white side of things
that doesn't mean anything because
they've just traded one piece each and
you can just castle and black will
probably castle at some point and we
have many many moves ahead this is going
to be a much longer game than the Hikaru
versus Lanier Dominguez game well
speaking of that came in Knight H2
played by karwana you know what he wants
he wants F4 and so on he has to push
those pawns so we'll see if he's able to
get everything here because if this Pawn
can get up the board that would be
really nice for him so
um let's go back to the game between
Hikaru and Lanier just because that's
deeper along here
and yep but let me grab that one
uh I like this I like this overlay
because if you don't realize uh the
names are at the bottom it looks like
you and I are playing you and I can
pretend to sit in the shoes of these
great players Okay so
Hikaru is a pawn up
but he is down more than five minutes
which makes me think that Lanier did not
lose this Pawn by mistake and he will
probably be winning it back very soon
Rook D3 doesn't quite win it back but it
activates the rook and forces white to
maybe play Knight D1 which is just the
just a very uh
not a pleasant move to make because now
you can't move anything
but
there's still some accuracy to be had
here so far though if Lanier gets out of
this completely unscathed Robert it
seems a tremendous preparation from him
right no I mean this is activity for the
cost of a pawn so
right now we see that the Knight on D1
is passive The Rook on D3 very active
and there are no more weaknesses in
Black's Camp the only weakness was
sacrifice jettisoned and so black has
all its activity
exactly right
maybe white is going to try to put the
Rook behind the c pawn and C3 C4 C5 in
the future bring the king over a little
bit that's sort of the plan uh Hikaru is
not a guy who
loses time for no reason let's put it
this way he's not a guy who's wasting
five six minutes of clock time and in
the size of no he he really just doesn't
exactly know how to untangle here he's
doing his best these guys have
processors in their brains that are
unbelievably fast so to see him down
five and a half minutes trying to find a
way to untangle here and make some
degree of progress is very interesting
and it just shows you that Queen's gamut
accepted voluntarily giving up the
center so early in the game but trying
to even win back a sacrifice Pawn a
little bit later is an opening that
requires extreme precision and very very
good memorization and linear has shown
that so far in game number one
yeah no this is great played by linear
is King in the center over here looking
quite nice and we'll see if that King
can Dash as well and
um yeah no it looks like a very nice
setup for him as Hikaru continues to
think have you ever seen Hikaru down six
minutes on the clock no this is what I
was saying I've I I'm shocked I'm sure
you can find games he he's unpleasant uh
in some sort of opening but he's nearly
down 50 of the time
hang out for one but I mean I think
White's moves are relatively
straightforward as well so it's not like
Hikaru has to worry about losing this
game in a few it's not that kind of
activity for black it just feels like
well I mean I prefer most of Black's
pieces especially the Rook on D3
compared to the Rook on A1 but you can't
attack another Pawn or anything like
that
yeah this will be a while either Hikaru
will find a way to bring his King a
little bit F1 E2
and get out of all this or black just
has a wonderful blockade what sometimes
happens here with black is you lose a
pawn
and you just get all this activity
you say I did my job a guy's low on time
I did my job but with opponents like
Hikaru you you can never really relax uh
some in the audience might remember the
game that he won against David Navarra
it was just a completely equal end game
and if you don't remember that game
because you don't even remember what you
had for breakfast that's completely fine
don't worry about it but Hikaru can win
the most equal of positions although
generally he's doing it from the
stronger side of the clock so five
minutes down winning in endgame
it's not simple but seven minutes is
still just so much time and it's an
eternity and if suddenly linear is
uncomfortable defending then he will not
succeed he will make a mistake and
suddenly the extra Pawn will be felt
for sure so I mean for a Hikaru game one
with the white pieces you'd really
prefer to get a more unbalanced position
something sharper something that gives
that gives a little more fight but now
linear is thinking so I do believe that
psychologically a car can start feeling
a little bit better because if you see
the evaluation bar Levy goes up a little
bit there and that might make your guard
doesn't know what the evaluation is but
every single move for a car bringing the
king towards the center trying to
activate those Knights it just feels
like if there's not 100 accuracy from
Lanier then he's not going to get this
done
I'm sort of confused what the idea here
is what is it King E2 Bishop B5 is that
what is the pla like if of course white
wants to bring the king to touch the
rook and then wanted to play F3 F4 which
is why Lanier just played the move G5
and G5 will prevent
white from playing
F4 himself
and removing the Knight and then trying
to win The Rook
and the only reason Hikaru hasn't moved
any closer with the King and is kind of
staring out the window looking at the
weather and calculating is because the
bishop for black is going to probably go
to B5 on the same diagonal and suddenly
white has walked directly into the line
of attack
not to mention that linear doesn't even
have to use the G Pawn as a Defender he
could use it as an aggressor with a move
like G5 G4
and the extra Pawn for white is not felt
it's not it's not quite there it's much
more sort of hoping to survive than
confidently standing and playing a
pivotal role in the position
right
no it's uh
yeah that's one I don't envy either
player because uh for Hikaru you know
you need to really find everything you
know a deep sort of idea a plan to get
you some play and for linear it's like
well I'm down a pawn and hopefully I can
keep this up that's the goal so um yeah
I don't know I think that both players
shouldn't be too unhappy but it's just
one of those games where you're going to
just dig deep
oh you got to dig super deep for all the
hype and for all of the number one
versus number two seed here this is
gonna be a it's gonna be a dirty Scrappy
end game grind that's what's gonna
that's what's going on here it's not
gonna be like our other game where we
had almost no trades but it's going to
be whether or not Hikaru can demonstrate
that okay maybe his preparation
was not having him in a situation up six
minutes on the clock but he won a pawn
and he created enough practical chances
and linear was unable to to deal with
them but
the problem in chess is that you have to
make moves
it's not just the rules you cannot just
sit there and go ah my position looks
good you know I did my job every move
you actually have to do something you
have to change something on the board
and that is where the variance pops in
I wonder if how I wonder if we are able
to see
you can
you can go over there and see what's
going on um those are the worst Rooks
I've ever seen
those are the worst Rooks
ever and yet the evaluation says zeros
what
is it it just feels like some uh Modern
Art Museum you know like we're supposed
oh this is the tragedy of the Rooks or
something we have to analyze this image
I I think we understand why they're
there he wants some kind of G5 move and
then once upassan happens H6 to be
defended but that's why Fabiano Queen C1
just saying no G Pawn push for you at
the end of those variations with
opposant H6 will be attacked three times
and we just saw andrekin smile and take
a sip because I think he's smiling at
Jesus Christ why do I have Rooks on H7
but the truth is he might still get a
lot of value out of playing the move G5
maybe maybe even right now at the end of
the whole sequence his Queen side could
be a little bit weak and if we follow
that sequence all the way down like G5
you know HG FG rookies at the end of it
there's going to be and that's why we
see A6 there we go so now the King on A8
is going to uh let's see you cannot
can't do it just yet but as
black plays Asics the king now no longer
has any liabilities wow Queen B2
Switching gears it looks like just going
for the B file maybe Queen will plant
itself on the B6 Square as well
uh so not afraid of g-pawn pushes is
Fabiano caruana no he's not
no he's not he's like do your worst
deal was G5 I guess
well you must it's forced As We Know
this by the way do you have to take or
can you play Rook hh1 and rotate over to
the other side actually I'm serious I I
guess taking is better well we're about
to find out because G5 was just played
and I I think your instinct is correct
to take on Passat you can also bring
this Rook over to H1 which would induce
the move H5 so I'm going to show that
quickly to show you why white would want
something like this because now for H5
we have a dark Square Bishop black does
not give me all of these dark squares
over here this bishop can actually just
Venture right into Black's position yep
exactly right white is asking questions
of black on all three sides of the board
at this point in fact it almost seems
like black cannot do anything if I'm
looking at this plane at this position
the only plan that I see is Knight A7
Knight B5
that's it I don't see anything else
because pushing the g-pawn forward you
cannot white will put the bishop there
and or play f2f4
I'm Robert I don't see anything else
no but I guess Dimitri's hoping that he
can continue to lock up this position a
bishop on E6 is not always the best
block hating piece of a past Pawn we are
seeing a variation uh this is happening
but Bishop on E6 can be kicked if
there's a knight coming to squarely F4
white doesn't have any Knights so this
actually is a full-on blockade here and
Levy I'm not really seeing how white can
crash through maybe later F3 and G4 but
it's going to be a very long story in
this game
Robert correct me if I'm wrong so I'm
actually trying to learn a bit more
myself about this position and I also
think the audience would benefit from
this in any in any position you have to
always evaluate what's TR what trades
would benefit aside the most and I think
in this position just looking at it if
black did not have a queen if it was
just queenless metal end game this is
completely like hopeless for black
because I think the queen prevents a lot
of expansion for white on the queen side
and covers the C2 square right so so
white struggles to move but with a queen
trade it would be game over and draken
would sit there waiting for Fabiano to
arrive and take all the cookies away
from him so it's very important that
Queen on A4 survives like a move like
Queen B5 and I think white is just
completely winning immediately right I
think it's a great point and I was just
drawing this era for fun but in all
seriousness if the Queens are traded
this white king might just go to G5 and
help and put pressure here but look what
Fabiano's doing he's gonna Rook back to
H1 Rook over to B1 and start trying to
put pressure on the black queen side
this bishop on G5 and the pawn on G3
stopped all of Black's play you need
pawns on dark squares to combat a dark
Square Bishop all of Black's pawns every
single one all seven are on might
squares this position is miserable for
Dimitri maybe he can hold but he will
never have an active plan unless his
Knight can sort of get into the game
maybe Knight d8 to F7 or as Levy was
mentioning bringing the Knight to B5 at
some point but
this doesn't look very appetizing no it
doesn't when you play E6 on the first
move you are immediately bestowing upon
yourself the burden of proof to make
your light squared Bishop useful it's
called the bad French bishop and in this
game there are seven out of eight pawns
still remaining on the board for black
and every single Pawn is on the same
color as the bishop
literally and the craziest thing is only
really one of them should move forward
ever and it's the b-pawn because if you
play a6a5 Then white will very quickly
go trade Queens some sort of rugby one
Queen B5 and you cannot trade Queens
with black you just literally will lose
the game that King is going to walk up
in fact Robert there is a world where
white can play Bishop F6 and walk the
king to G5 right now
and if the king is safe like Knight d8
you could just take it but of course you
should trade Queens but it's just so
funny uh I think this is just a matter
of time I don't know how you feel but
this is a very nice display so far from
Fabiano I feel like looking at the eval
bar just it's like wrong you know it's
like this position is so miserable for
black that even though objectively it's
fine it feels losing for all the reasons
that Levy was highlighting Queen trade
is terrible for black this King can walk
up on the dark squares into G5 litter
black has no active play of his own so
let's leave Dimitri to this task here
because it's not going to be fun and
it's going to be difficult so he'll
probably start thinking he just played
B6 now let's go back to Hikaru versus
Dominguez because things are changing
over there
um Hikaru has pushed his Pawn I just saw
this move played Pawn to F4 finally
kicking this Knight out of the center
and while the evaluation still hovering
around even Levy it's becoming a
different type of game
it really is becoming a different type
of game I this is a very very spicy game
now and the time Advantage is 15 seconds
as of finishing that sentence so
complete turnaround it was six minutes
for Lanier he's finally starting to feel
some of that pressure that I was
describing earlier of okay I did my job
why why is this so difficult now I did
everything I was supposed to do
but I'm still down upon and my opponent
is threatening my knight and he's also
threatening straight up a fork Knight B2
is just straight up a fork it's equal
here because there's probably some
tactics
I just don't know where they are Robert
where are the tactics why is it zeros so
Knight C4 stops the fork on B2 but it
does allow this Knight to F2 with a
different Fork hitting the rook and
hitting the pawn so maybe the move G3 I
don't really want to play that move but
I can throw it in I believe uh at the
moment it's a little risky but the whole
point is that you can't really allow my
Pawn to land on H2 so taking the Knight
feels off the table and then maybe I
won't lose this Pawn here but
I love it this is getting a little bit
sharp although I guess the Knight on D1
another point Sorry to kind of go on and
on here but the Knight on D1 is doing an
important job of stopping Rook E3 check
so maybe Knight C4 directly is
acceptable
it's a very sharp position I really
don't like that linear is getting solo
on time
uh it really feels like the game is is
turning here all you need to do is give
Hikaru one opportunity to find a
resource
and the right situation to do it in
especially when you start
spending so much time thinking
and he will find it
he will absolutely find it I just
realized this Knight can also go for a
fork Maxi five
yeah Knight C5 Knight B2 Knight F2 it's
unbelievable yeah so exactly I was gonna
say 95 but I guess there's
who doesn't play any of those motions
please can you too
[Laughter]
very honestly honestly good move because
he's keeping the status quo he remains
up a pawn and you highlighted the
biggest
Plus in his position is on the clock
Hikaru Nakamura now up a minute and a
half he was down six minutes before he
was but Rook d8 is a classy move just
retreating completely retreating all the
way back no Knight C5 forks no Rook D6
E5 stuff none of that all the way back
and he's just asking Hikaru make a move
do something and and it's actually
shockingly hard to do something
it's one of these big decisions that you
have to ask is Knight E3 available for
white right now because you would love
to trade pieces if you trade these
Knights on E3 all of a sudden Black's in
big trouble so Knight E3 is black and
play Bishop B5 I'm hoping for a check
against this King and then the activity
that follows uh can you at some point
take on B3 by Rook D2 check needs to be
considered but Hikaru asked the question
and now it's up to Lanier
okay it's the best move here like Knight
B2 or Bishop B5 of course taking the
Knight on E3 is
hopeless for black white plays C3 C4 and
is just straight up winning at that
point uh so that that doesn't work
what does black do
oh this is such a tough spot look at
linear linear is just a linear is acting
like a tikara's movie he's like cleaning
his glasses he has two minutes just two
minutes he's got a he's gotta come up
with something now and this is not easy
because the next move for white could
just be pushing the pawn right if that
Knight moves up goes the pawn to C4 and
then it might not stop going forward
from there so Knight B2 is interesting
you take away Rook D1 which might be
White's next idea and you can also go
into D3 Square which attacks the F4 Pawn
so Knight B2 is fascinating a bishop B5
feels like a very natural idea as well
although after Bishop B5 there might
just be Knight D4 and all of a sudden it
car is threatening to trade pieces or
why is that a threat you're up a pawn
you want to get into an end game where
black lacks counter play
I mean from my eyes Bishop B5 Knight D4
looks terrible for black because it
expedites the trading process whoa and
okay what oh
simple Fork
wow
could this really be the solution I
think this is the biggest difference
Levy between talking about Chess and
thinking about the game because yeah
this did not even come close to entering
my mind
yeah wow I was the last thing I I
thought Knight B2 for sure but I'm sure
Knight B2 had some sort of refutation
and Knight B2 is one of those moves that
you kind of gamble in low time you play
it and you just go ah it looks cool I
got an ID3 or something and your
opponent actually thinks they don't
gamble at all they call your bluff and
you have nothing but Robert which Pawn
do you okay just takes on G4 Robert can
I be honest I forgot it was hanging I
just straight I forgot G4 was able to be
captured I appreciate your honesty I
would take the B3 Pawn now for a linear
because I want to have this outside pass
Pawn a huge strength in an end game like
this the Knight can go back to C5 where
blockade's whites passer and tax E4 so I
think winner should take on B3 here but
I'm guessing their problems with opening
files and allowing this Rook on C1 to
get into the game
yeah I can also argue for E4 because it
sort of prevents The Rook moving on C1
and you have maybe a rook D2 in the
future but I agree it just feels correct
to take on B3 oh well you have a linear
has 80 seconds it's a 50 50. and this is
exactly how you end up losing to Hikaru
in the long run he just plays all the
best moves and makes the position
complicated for you and you lose your
seven minute time Advantage okay Knight
takes B3 is played he has 111 on the
clock he's now down two minutes this is
so scary I think the issue for linear is
not his current clock but you know that
these decisions will take six seconds
seven seconds there's a two second
increment linear is a very good Blitz
player but bullet is a whole different
animal and you're playing it's Hikaru
Nakamura the bullet chess champion you
don't want any part of eventually E5 and
maybe a knight sink its teeth into F6 so
of course The Rook needs to move right
now but it just feels like hit car will
keep the tension to the right moment and
then start creating threats
Hikaru might just play Rook C2 here to
cover anything on on the D2 square and
ask linear what's next but then linear
has time to play a5a4 and there's no
Rook A2 because of Knight C1 well
there's no Rook A2 at this level for
they have the average player Rook A2
looks fantastic I'm just gonna win the
pawn in the future but yeah there's
Forks all over the board so
he plays Rook D1
wow just going into this night end game
huh a non-zero chance that taken D1 is
acceptable you typically don't want to
trade when you're down to Pieces you're
down a pawn here as black but with this
outside pawn it will distract at the
very least White's King and then there
may not be enough material remaining to
start picking up uh remaining pawns or
creating a passer so Rook takes D1 not
the question but Levy 45 seconds now for
linear he's got to start making moves
more quickly he's gotta start making
moves he no longer has any time to relax
I really feel like he's played this game
way too relaxed and that can happen when
you have such a success in the opening
and he trades
wow the evaluation goes up to plus 1.7
and it's gonna fluctuate a little bit
here that was an incorrect decision and
one that took him a lot of time
that is a shot are you shocked I'm
shocked at that decision because you
just like there is a very high chance
you were just straight up lost here end
games are theoretical they're kind of
scientific they're solved so you might
just straight up be lost here I'm
shocked he's basically saying Nokia Cara
I don't think you have a way to win this
and he could be right because they're
not that many pawns remaining and so if
you can trade some more pawns and uh
just keep this white king at Bay he has
chances you see a trade that helps the
defensive task now what does white need
a passer to start moving a pastor over
here to start moving the C Pawn is
blockaded the a pawn is free to go up to
A4 at some moment just to keep White's
pieces Frozen and that's the big thing
so if linear has calculated this
correctly and I trust linear and
honestly love it the Olympiad everyone
was marveling at Lanier's end game
prowess uh then he knows that he can
hold this with right play but not with
24 seconds
that's the biggest difference right now
is the time yeah for sure and it's
fascinating that he goes into an end
game down a pawn with three completely
isolated Pawn Islands but the only
reason he's not completely lost is his
Pawn on A6 and he's not even in a rush
to push it it's just there the second he
pushes it and actually gets a little
closer to White's pieces and white can
spend some time walking over and winning
it so he's just gonna leave it there
maybe he'll push it once it's just gonna
make it difficult for you Karo but now
c4 and Hikaru keeps F4 G2 and H2 because
he wants a cluster of Pawns all right
there's A5 Lanier has indicated he's
pushing now is there King F5 he probably
could have protect his Knight that way
he brings his Knight back hitting the
pawn and if C5 where's this Knight going
I don't know
oh gosh seven seconds for Lanier to make
that decision by the way not looking
good and by the way you don't even have
to push you can play King D4 King C5 oh
I like to look at that it's a knight F5
check you play that you gained 0.2
seconds so at least he's got some mouse
speed he's Gotta Move
oh he goes right at the punching that's
a bad decision it's a losing decision in
fact
why is it losing
it's just here
oh my gosh you cut the king off
he can't stop the pawn wow what a finish
and Robert we called it what a clutch
performance from Hikaru from start to
finish in this game
oh my goodness that extra Pawn he had
compensation for it but he didn't have
the time to play all the accurate moves
that's what happens in sort of gambits
that is a big start for card knock more
linear will have to strike back but we
do have another game in progress Fabiano
caruano with the white pieces I can't
even count the material is he up
something there's so many F pawns and
what is this now he's not he was up now
with six six I believe it's the weirdest
structure I've ever seen also black has
two pass pawns the g h pawns are
literally past Pawns
they're just seemingly more easily
blockaded than these F and E pawns and I
believe that Fabiano will try to trade
off the Bishops because if the Bishops
go away then these pawns really start
rumbling yes Robert I have a question
for you does why have two past F pawns
right now or is that one past F1
I'm gonna go with
I'm gonna go two just for this position
two two right kind of I don't the
philosophical question I don't know
because at some point we want to put
upon F6 and then bring the next one to
F5 so it just feels like they're both
Runners that we need
yeah how did we even get here by the way
okay B5 apparently computer doesn't like
and here's this one simple plan Bishop
to H3 F5 push these parts great bands by
the way Simple Plan
unintentional reference yes uh
how do you stop this by black
this whole game has just felt like all
fobby
that's why you don't play the French
defense against five into car one I said
it as soon as we saw it don't do it
yeah it felt like a game four opening
when you need to win with black it does
not feel like a game one opening you
play e45 game one that's what you do
right I
that's so surprising I wonder if Dimitri
he plays Sicilian he plays the Petrov
you don't really want to play the
Sicilian against Fargo either we saw
what happened to mvo and the candidates
all that preparation just bashed him on
the head and then playing the Petrov
against the world's greatest Petrov
expert maybe you're on the palm she can
take his claim that title but either way
look at these pawns Larry this is just
straightforward stuff this is crazy this
is a race of Epic Proportions you have E
and F going together you have a b about
to break through on the queen side the
problem there is that the only Pawn that
will survive the rubble is the C pawn
and it's just not far enough
it's just white will play CB white will
not play a B although a b is probably
also okay but I think just F4 A5 E6 F7 I
don't
where's the plant here for for black
yeah E6 I guess the idea is Rook C6 and
try to get the Rook over here that might
also be too slow by the way
um I can show A variation just very
quickly and we'll go back to the
position is after E7 if you start you
know trying to take these pawns well
then I believe this King comes up and
somehow this is winning oh because you
take here yeah yeah
oh okay well I thought that this would
be a mistake but no just eat everything
and win the game but that's why Fabiano
will take his time he plays King F4 I'll
play King F5 and then push the Pawns and
he does ultimately do it this way and
yes black gets the black gets the C Pawn
but
it's not good enough and ultimately
white can even sack The Rook on C1 maybe
in some position in the future and
promote so what's gonna happen is white
will play E6 and maybe E7
and that will be that
and five and also had in the clock so
wisely using his time here no need to
just push the past pawns without
calculating here he goes E6 as mentioned
C2 white pawns are mobilizing first
although if this kind of situation
happens with a trade on C1 here the
blackwork lands G2 next that could be
devastating so he does plant his Rook on
C1 in front of the package patience is
it a mistake plus still plus two
there's a way to maybe blunder Rook C6
King E5 Rook H5 oops oh
and G2 played wow the problem with
trying to push two pawns laterally is
The Rook covers all the squares right so
the rook and C1 defends everything and
the white king is going to E5 you still
need extreme Precision here
I think King F5 is just a good move
because the point for black is some it's
something like a G1 and C1 but you lose
both of your past pawns and then white
pushes so E7 first and still good
an error somehow
it's beyond my pay grade understanding
why that was a mistake and he had some
other way
to go forward
to bring this King up right
yeah King E5 King D6 has seemed very
natural to me
yeah King F5 King E6 just bring the king
into the game the king is a weapon in
the end game and there's king of five
Rook G does not allow F7
G1 one oh goodness
this is this is you could screw this up
man this is anything but over
I'm confused
yeah Robert I actually don't like this
anymore I don't even know what you play
here I how about Rook H2 and if you
promote I sack this Rook for one Pawn I
said wrote this rope for the other pawn
and then I get a queen okay but Rook
h2h3
I didn't get any further than that I'm
just gonna give it one move idea oh my
gosh this is crazy five is down to 25
seconds I'm nervous man
he's nervous look at him he plays F7 G1
takes take oh the Evo goes to you even
oh my gosh he was winning some other way
and he could lose this there's a check
on G5
yeah oh he's gonna make a draw
is it oh my gosh if the F Pawn was on F4
there oh no there wouldn't be Rook A3
well actually there would be oh it's
covered
so can you take on D5 is
what's happening after that
yeah Fabi is unhappy with himself
because that was definitely winning but
Robert can we see how
um sure and it's a draw
it looks like at this moment here this
is a critical moment already in this day
and
all right I guess F4 is just a winning
move
yeah of course the yeah if you promote
and do this whole thing
now when we have Rook A3 check first
Levy that's the key oh my gosh that's so
deep the point is that now the king
moves somewhere let's say to B7 and when
you get the queen black queen second and
there's Checkmate about to happen
because White Checks yeah first
Robert F4 was an unbelievable move that
that you literally have to use your last
bit of
artillery and rotate The Rook over that
I I don't think that's findable I I
really just don't
what an incredible game and kudos to on
draken because he could have went down
multiple times what an absolutely
unbelievable finish
that's just a ridiculous play so uh
drawing this one so it is half half here
and we do want to give another shout out
to our presenting sponsor brave because
Brave means private browsing and so much
more by default Brave blocks ads and
trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com
chess and we are going to head on out
here the second games here in this these
route of 16 matches between Hikaru
Nakamura and Leonard Dominguez 500
carwana Dimitri on Drake and we'll
resume here at the 2022 chess.com Global
championships presented by Brave
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the 2022
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave we see Hikaru Nakamura on
stream pineapple shirt pineapple in the
back and Levy you know a thing or two
about those play buttons that he has in
his background
yes I do I was not expecting to have to
discuss YouTube milestones in the middle
of uh the last online round of such a
prestigious and wonderful event that
leads up to a live final but yes on top
of also being a dominant chess player
you know
he said you could you you just combined
YouTube and Accolade all in one
um unfortunately on these cards they
don't put the amount of subscribers you
have on YouTube but uh yes he has quite
a lot and his path thus far has been
winning against Vazquez and Navara very
convincingly I must say the matchup
against Navara in particular was just
dominant from start to finish and I
would say in that first game he did
exactly what he did to David Navara in
the second end game that he won he is a
nightmare to play against in any
position where the balance is 0.2 or
something along those lines yeah and it
was a shaky start against his first
round opponent because when he played
against Vasquez he wasn't just winning
games like people expect him to and also
he probably expected of himself he also
was worse in some positions from the
white side of things so he's found his
footing here in the cgc the rapid time
Patrol 15 min plus two second increment
different than his classical chess
successes at the Grand Prix and the
candidates and then here online he of
course has been an absolute monster but
Leonard fingers no slouch his opponent
here it's one nothing in hikaru's favor
that was a nice end game grind Lanier
needs to be consistent on the clock Levy
that's my biggest takeaway from their
first game
yep that's exactly right
but Lanier is
not
the guy who maybe if if Humanity needs
to win one game with white you
necessarily call I might call report a
report is a guy who's going to make
things super weird in the first 10 moves
and he might win he might lose it might
be spectacular Lanier is going to start
the game
the way I would expect with E4 there it
is and we are probably going to have a
Berlin
and wow
an open invitation to accept the Berlin
so linear yeah Lanier plays this line he
doesn't play the end game he plays the
symmetrical structure and tries to
squeeze well maybe he'll try to squeeze
the juice out of the pineapple
now that is a stellar reference and
people have known Hikaru Nakamura as a
tactical whiz kid growing up and uh
playing along the circuit but you know I
think Peter doesn't get enough credit
for his endgame technique he is
extremely strong in an end game and
we're not fully in an end game yet but
you look at the position symmetrical
Pawn structure uh the game is quite
balanced but Bishop F4 tries to take the
game into slightly different territory
if in fact black wants to start trading
pieces dragging the queen away from the
defense of the D4 Pawn black does get to
steal that pawn in the center but white
has such a lead in development that
oftentimes the player with the black
pieces regrets stealing the pawn so Levy
a car spending time right now he must be
somewhat familiar with the position do
you think he's trying to determine where
to take this game or is it a specific
line he's looking at
he's remembering games he's probably
remembering some of his analysis and
it's sort of what we're seeing in the
last game too just because he's spending
time and potentially even getting a few
minutes down on the clock doesn't
necessarily mean anything bad of course
he is very slowly fading further and
further out of frame as he floats off
into the land of pineapples but that
first game just basically showed that it
makes absolutely no difference if he's
down seven minutes on the clock
I guess has anyone given hikar the
nickname Pineapple Express can we give
him that nickname
wow what what so he's he's pineapple was
that what was I was that king of Gotham
is that what you called me yeah Robert's
just dishing out nicknames do you have a
nickname no
you have a catchphrase as a nickname
right there's no ain't no chess without
has something like that
yeah that uh is what the people say I
don't know if it's true uh but I do
appreciate nonetheless and how about
this I mean Lanier has 15 minutes nine
seconds the guy has more time than he
started with he's attacking the queen
trying to drag it away from this Knight
in E8 you do not want to get back right
Checkmate of course that car is not
going to fall for that is F6 the move
yes it is but that opens up the light
squares against the black king
yeah um my dog is very intrigued by this
game as you can see
he just got really riled up and just
started standing on me and uh and and
smelling my face going oh Berlin let me
get let me get some of that I want to
learn some of these Berlin positions
this is really interesting because you
generally don't see such crazy tactics
in Berlin territory Robert I wouldn't be
surprised if the best move here is
something like King f8 because I feel
like King h8 just seems a bit
I don't know feeble King but King f8 is
their Queen E4 oh goodness what are we
looking at here yeah that's a double
attack going after that Black Canyon hey
card doesn't know the position right he
he may have studied it and he may have
this in some file on his computer but
right here right now it doesn't feel
like he knows every last movement Lanier
is still moving instantly the eval bar
just it went a little bit in Black's
favor after that move but that's not
what dictates if this is a good choice
or not right Levy I mean it's still
hovering around even but linear knows
this probably like six more moves
in multiple directions too he will very
quickly know if Hikaru messes something
up but the benefit of playing an opening
like the Berlin is that even if you do
make a slight inaccuracy it's very
little
in terms of an evaluation swing whereas
in Sicilians if you play a move that's
not good you might very quickly get a
lost position but doesn't it feel like a
sicilian more than a Berlin right
there's a open King it's a pawn
sacrifice it feels like white has a lot
to play for it feels like a Karo Khan
but black did not know that they were
supposed to put their pawns on light
squares because generally you have these
two like pawns right next to each other
on C6 and E6 but in this case you have
them on the dark squares instead and it
does it does feel a bit problematic and
let's not also forget that white is a
pawn down like if Lanier does not pull
out something in this game he will
probably just lose in the similar
fashion he did in the last game where if
Hikaru gets the pawn and goes back to
his base and says okay come get me and
linear fails it's gonna be 2-0
that's true so far he's defending well
and lenier taking his first huge thing
of the game already spent 10 seconds on
this move how could he but the move F4
is very tempting to get this bishop out
here but as F4 is played and then you're
just trying to recall his prep uh we are
gonna get the car one on Drake and game
underway so when that one begins we're
gonna take you right there for the
opening stage let's do that on draken
with the white pieces he's lucky to be
tied in this match he's very fortunate
that he probably going to put him away
yeah
you could also argue toward the end
Fabiano if he didn't have Perpetual it
could have been really really dangerous
Fabiana was very very upset as you could
see on camera
and does that mean that momentum is now
on Dimitri's side when you escape like
that and you get a free pass for the
next game or does it mean that you're
now a bit relaxed you're like oh I I
survived I can sort of do what I want I
don't know one of two things can happen
either Fabiano
overextends a little bit now with black
and just plays a little bit too
aggressively or Dimitri
is a little bit too confident and well
one of those two is happening right now
because we are getting a pawn sacrifice
line
early in this opening what is this I
think they're like Knight takes E5 and
queen A4 check type of moves here so
that's the
point of the variation but look at
Dimitri's face he wasn't expecting
Bishop takes before there he's like what
is fabino doing and Fabiano is
sacrificing first upon back on E5 that
was recaptured now he's giving up
material on C6 so Fabiano in a sharp
variation seems to know what he's doing
Levy and I was going to say even before
the sequence I don't like playing to
direct variations against Fabiano I
think you should keep it a little bit
more uh tame and then pounce later
absolutely if the choices against
Fabiano are on move 10 I'm going to
sacrifice upon
and then I'm going to play a super
forcing line maybe he doesn't know it
versus I'm gonna play 18 moves of theory
and then I came up with this interesting
idea that's quite nuanced and it's still
equal but that's my chance I'm gonna
choose the second one because choosing
Fabiano probably doesn't remember it
it's just kind of disrespectful to
Fabiano I feel like uh of course that
was not on draken's strategy but the
strategy was more like this line is
quite crazy and there was a chance that
I can catch him but it doesn't seem to
be happening right now
this White Castle here or take on C6 I
don't think you can take on C6 even
though Bishop H3 to my eyes not allowing
white to Castle and five in a planks so
quickly like he he entered this for a
reason so if I'm Dimitri I just castle
and then try to figure things out from
there but I think we have to go back to
the other game I understand we just got
here the opening uh you know it's just
finishing in this one but the other game
between linear and Hikaru look at this
like the less bunch of moves happen
where F4 chased the bishop it had to
take Rook B1 the bishop had to go to A3
Queen A5 the bishop had to go to C5 so a
series of only moves and Levy Lanier has
spent so much time he's giving up seven
seconds off his initial clock and Hikaru
once again down a lot of time and there
are a bunch of threats in the position
and the car goes Knight D6 giving up C7
hey well listen when the options are
lose upon or get checkmated in one move
maybe some of the audience would
disagree of the of the verdict but I
would probably lose my Pawn on C7
instead of getting mated this still
looks absolutely horrifying though like
the three of your pieces have literally
not moved what move is it uh 22. how is
that possible
never develop that's how you play chess
these days his he hasn't moved three
pieces literally he has I right I don't
think that single one of them has moved
a single time
you are correct
how is that acceptable I'm not saying he
did anything wrong I'm saying uh linear
has played such a practical line very
very difficult but Hikaru is finding
only moves
and I would put them with Bishop B3
thinking that I can continue the attack
but maybe there's some bailout like
Queen takes C7 and if we trade Queens
here I'll just show this line very
quickly it's kind of a funny repetition
of sorts Rook B8 Knight A6 you can't
take the Knight over here why is this
winning oh cause Rook D1 at the end or
something
I thought this would just be like a a
repetition Bishop D5 or something
ridiculous one I guess yeah black can't
really move so funny you get to a
position like this and it's just
completely winning when I was even Rook
D1 looks uh pretty good
yeah totally winning for white wow
look at you trying to find a draw
amongst the wind and it was still
winning
we can't all be a new scary can't we oh
no Robert I was so hoping you were above
that I knew what I was getting myself
into oh well you know sometimes you have
to give a niche a little bit of flack
obviously in each Geary one of the
remaining contestants in this field he
plays Pavel pancreatov on Wednesday so
that will be a fun one to watch and
actually Anish played maybe the best
match of the entire event when he beat
Raonic sedwani the guy was on fire he
played brilliant chess in every single
game and he just blanked the guy
dominant performance and of all the
players in the round of 16 you can argue
he has
well I don't want to say necessarily the
easiest but he has the the technically
the easiest on paper he has he's playing
the lowest seat of a group and that's
five when crowd of took down vishyanand
and nausea so does he get an elevated
status with two absolutely incredible
upsets does he suddenly just jump to two
seed on Merit of beating two incredible
players before him or do we just look at
the stats and the stats say that this is
not a number one versus number two and
initial has to take it seriously for
sure so we're gonna see how he does but
I feel like we shouldn't be talking
about a matchup that's not even on the
screen we have Hikaru here trying to
solve this
20 by 20 Rubik's cube of a of a Berlin
defense and if he does it will be
incredibly frustrating I think for
linear because
how do you get to this position and just
cannot
win it cannot convert it it's all about
this King I mean this King does not have
Luft right now so there are all sorts of
background Checkmate ideas uh if you can
for example C6 is the easiest one to
illustrate you immediately drop your
knight on D6 because Rook E8 will be
Checkmate if the black queen leaves the
last rank over there so linear 13
minutes 24 seconds Hikaru 640. we never
see Hikaru down this kind of time but
Lanier is just playing preparation deep
lines and now he needs to keep his foot
on the gas pedal and not let hikar out
of it yeah Hikaru finally develops his
Bishop because if he hadn't Knight C7
and Rook E8 would have just won the game
for white it would have been this crazy
line where
white can infiltrate on f8 but this is
an important move now because if Knight
C7 there is Rook C8 yes but we have to
show why because rookie a check I love
your variation loving Knight takes E8
check minute one
down yes okay
why is uh oh Knight C7 also no no hold
on I'm very perplexed uh why is Knight
C7 Rook C8 not just winning on the spot
it is right
well or at least this variation would be
no no this variation yeah was it winning
I thought
or was I relying too much on the lag of
our no it's no better but it's not
winning maybe there's Rook D1 or
something like that just to ah yeah yeah
yeah okay counter pin and the background
problems persist but obviously Hikaru
would love this position it's the best
position he said all game and it makes
his life as easy as possible
so what should white play if not taking
on C7
hmm Bishop can you just play Bishop B3
and continue to be down a pawn but have
better pieces
but maybe C6 then
yeah there might be like 97 I mean I
that that's what I'm hoping for
but the fact that linear is thinking
obviously at some point he leaves
preparation he needs to use his brain
instead of his computer prep it just
doesn't feel like a good trajectory I
really feel like hikara should be happy
about this so why don't we leave linear
to continue thinking should we head back
on over the other game you think
yeah we should it's crazy it's the same
exact situation in back-to-back games
it's literally identical down upon
potentially asking his opponent a bunch
of questions and Hikari just answering
all of them no problems
and you know Hikaru can give that kind
of uh Time advance to his opponent
because we know how quick he makes
decisions and great decisions at that so
we'll leave a car and Lanier and we'll
come back here and the pawn in C6 is
still a Target but there's now a pawn H3
so the bishop is not leaving G2 anytime
soon and his blacks turn this position
Levy I really like fabiana's position
with his activity
me too I like the bishop on B4 I like
how it's well protected on A5
I don't exactly know what
white can even do here maybe slow
expansion on the queen side with Queen
C2 but he already played Queen C1 so
he's obviously not interested in playing
Queen C2 otherwise he would have played
Queen C2 uh Knight B5 yeah and I don't
know can you take it and
just like yes you're improving black
structure but maybe it doesn't matter
maybe there's a way to get at those
pawns but I wouldn't be so sure
be 94 but then black is going Knight D4
I don't know
I don't know what to play here I don't
think you want to see the Nightline on
D4 as you're indicating so Knight b5cb
that feels wrong because Black's pawns
are faster you have a rook Behind the B
Pawn then you can push to A4 and it just
seems like you're handing black a very
fun position although the long term with
these Pawns in the center could be nice
for white so
it is really a difficult moment for
andrekin and I'm not surprised to see
he's down two minutes on the clock
yeah I had an idea to go Knight B5 CB
and then D4 D5 I don't know if we can
put that on the board let me just see
how bad that is but Knight B5 uh CB and
then D4 but is the best move there
Bishop C4 I really wanted to play to to
try like this but I'm sure yeah I'm sure
yeah it's Bishop C4 and black just
doesn't get blockaded which is very
important because if black actually
allows D5 I think white has a completely
reasonable position I don't know like H6
D5 just something like that yeah I I
feel like white can actually push
forward uh quite a bit here with some
space but Bishop C4 and you just shut
white down instructive moment that you
shouldn't improve your opponent's Pawn
structure but uh
yeah I don't know I don't think Dimitri
knows because Knight D4 is such a huge
threat trying to jump into B3 but also
take this Knight and remove the guard
with a fork on E2 so
Dimitri is not enjoying this position I
mean look at him he's calculating uh
he's clearly focused and I feel like two
games in Fabiano has shown uh just good
play right after the opening and I just
think he hasn't had a bad position thus
far
yeah but I just realized that I've been
very hesitant about this entire position
because I forgot that Dimitri didn't
lose game one this whole time I'm like
oh what's Dimitri gonna do here and the
tradition actually doesn't matter
because he didn't lose the first game so
if he kind of does nothing and this game
just liquidates well he tried something
it didn't work but it's an equal match
and I'm just still in complete shock
that he managed to make a comeback in
the last game he actually is under no
pressure to win this game so
yeah maybe it's not as bad as as I
thought I was actually very down on his
position but maybe he can find a way out
yeah that is a nice thing not a must win
scenario by any means for on draken uh
the same might not be able to be said
for
Leno Dominguez who lost game one and if
he doesn't get game two he could be
eliminated after just three games here
in the round of 16 but let me I
mentioned the clock two minutes ago now
I'm drinking down to 7 25. it's ticking
ticking his position's not really clear
how to proceed here I think if I were on
draken I would try to find a way to
liquidate and force pieces off and try
to ensure I can make that half point
it's an intro oh interesting wow so
you're already saying it's time to
consider some sort of bailout rather
than
trying to find a way to play for
Advantage you think black has basically
proven
that the position is completely stable
and in the long run only he wow King H2
after two and a half minutes of thought
is not a good sign
because if you if this was bullet you
play King H2 instantly right
so wow Knight D4 anybody it's
threatening night I mean look how
quickly Fabiana played that Knight E4
look at him take a sip I like that
confident sip of water like yeah you
would have thought but is he just worse
here
what is he confident about exactly
so I think if Knight B3 he's gonna play
something like Queen F4 Queen E5 right
he's gonna go for that that actually
looks great so it might be three queen
of fortnite a one Queen E5 doesn't that
just look we'll show this on the
analysis board so Knight B3 hits the
queen of Rook with a fork the queen
jumps out if you take this Rook on A1
there's Queen E5 and Levy called it
threatening Checkmate the only way to
stop it is F6 but you drop first the
bishop with check then the knight in the
corner two pieces for The Rook a winning
position for on draken so
Knight B3 Queen F4 and I wonder if you
could throw in I know F5 doesn't
well
Maybe
it's a risky Choice that's for sure
what if you play
nope
I thought I had an idea
I don't have an idea maybe it's simple
chess just F6
just blunt the bishop The Rook is still
an attack if the Rook leaves the a file
A4 A3 happens before you know it and
we're not seeing this because Fabiano
started with the move
after night for age six Queen F4 played
anyway and it's back to an even game
fascinating so okay Dimitri only did
this entire sequence because of that
line with Queen E5 it's the only reason
that he played that at all was because
Queen F4 Queen E5 existed and it's
interesting that Fabiano didn't even go
for the fork and decided I'm gonna stop
H6 altogether
but now I guess Knight takes E2 is even
not working because Queen E5 and there's
some sort of lateral hit
on the night and there's mate and E6 is
hanging which more than anything else is
the problem so Rook P5
sure should that be it like you're
scaring me with Queen E5 but then Knight
F6 no or is that end game not a problem
oh that looks gross that looks how is
this anything
like but terrible for black just give
away the nice yeah so like we get this
position
does this really just say even like
point point two point one are you
serious this is I guess the a pawn is a
huge asset for black really that's
that's all it is because if the a pawn
was a I don't know a B7 this would be
miserable for black
I think in the long run a computer would
would maybe hold for black but I think
as a human it's very very uh all your
pawns are so weak this is okay you have
four Pawn Islands it's extremely
impressive to have four Pond Islands
when you have more pawns on the board
than you don't meaning you have five out
of eight remaining but you have four
Pawn Islands that's super impressive
well we'll uh leave Fabiano in this
difficult moment we'll see how he
handles the threat of Queen E5 it's a
really big choice now and he looks like
he's a bit nervous let's go back to
Nakamura and Dominguez that one has
changed quite a bit there is a pawn no
longer on B7 so in the last few moves
after the bishop developed Retreat 93
just
threatening both the bishop on F5 and
Rook to D1 that's where the Knight came
out to E4 but then that allowed linear
to grab a Pawn on B7 and here we are
maybe I was wrong I'm perfectly happy if
I am incorrect that Hikaru knew this
variation more deeply than I gave him
credit for
I was actually about to offer you a
conspiracy theory I'm very glad you
started with that so we're sort of on
the same page I have a theory
what if Hikaru has a read on linear and
he knows that if he goes into Ultra deep
water with linear but pretends like he
doesn't exactly know what he's doing and
gets down about five or six minutes on
the clock Lanier will relax and in that
second phase of the game hikara will
immediately turn up the speed and linear
reacts poorly to that what if that is
hikaru's read it could be a complete
coincidence two games in a row we have
the exact same situation Robert what if
this is a strategy
could that actually be what we're
looking at here
it is viable some people do slow down in
that opening stage just to present an
image that they are not aware of the
best continuation so that is certainly
possible and I think that Hikaru has
done a tremendous job out you know with
the opening with the difficult moments
that arise and then after the opening
especially that's been his best part
because in this game we're getting a
repetition if the White Queen were to
leave this queen lands on D2 threading
The Rook threading the Knight threading
Queen F2 check and then white might just
lose so the only reason Queen D2 is not
available is because the queen needs to
protect the rook in the corner and we
may see a kind of draw by repetition
between ikaru and Lanier
and Hikaru was never in trouble in this
game the only thing that made us think
he was in trouble was the time usage
time usage aside he played basically a
perfect game of Defense he just absorbed
what could have been a dangerous line of
preparation but when you give him 15
minutes on the clock then he will just
neutralize you know it's not going to be
three minutes not gonna be one minutes
15 minutes and well he's barely even
down on time anymore so that is my
conspiracy theory of the day but we'll
see what happens in the next two games
yeah it looks like this one might just
become a draw instantly with a queen A7
Queen B7 shuffling and Lanier he's
calculating he might try to figure out
if his queen go anywhere else I just
don't see it Queen takes C6 there's
already Queen D2 rook's under attack
your knight is going to be loose as
mentioned all these threats so what can
linear do besides Queen A7 I wouldn't
want to venture into Queen A6 just feels
like you're risking more than any
potential reward
I absolutely agree as we have for the
second game in a row finally about 15 to
20 minutes after the game began
Hikaru is finally up on time again and I
think this happened in the last game as
well around five four five minutes on
the clock so
yeah it's
there we are
well I'm looking at the other game as
well they're just going down the
variations we were discussing so let's
uh stay here for a moment just because
not too much has happened the queens
were trading the other game but linear
has a big Choice he either makes the
draw on the spot with Queen A7 align the
repetition and all right Hikaru I think
is just going to be happy let's put in
the point and there it is the draw is in
the books
a car leads one half half and Dominguez
he better
figure out what to do if he if not when
if he gets white in game four because he
needs to survived game three with black
before we get there absolutely
absolutely he's that's extremely
frustrating you cannot beat a player
when he plays like that Hikaru has been
so far Untouchable in two rounds
just completely Untouchable and we've
seen this before and each Geary showed
up against Ronald saidwani
it was never close Lavon aronian Sam
Savion was not close you did not have a
matchup like Wesley versus Jeffrey which
is a main event that we all would pay uh
for paper you know pay-per-view out of
pocket to see you sometimes just have a
situation where a guy is in great form
and there's nothing the other guy can do
so Lanier has to turn it around in the
next game and most certainly by game
number four
what's going on in this one though
well there's a point hanging of six but
the party two is loose so E3 White's
Pawn structure is obviously better but
is there going to be an A4 C5 A3 and
even if black loses a pawn you have some
serious potential with your passer
running down the flank
yeah I kind of am shocked by the
willingness to enter into all of this
territory from Fabi we looked at the
same game and you called it gross to use
your word but I guess he just thinks
that the activity is sufficient and King
G7 and it's one it's one of the ugliest
Pawn structures of all time in any end
game but there are enough Dynamics I
think to make it not completely lost
like what if Bishop C5 here I just don't
ship C5 D3 to D4
uh you probably have to do that
because what else is White gonna do all
of Black's pawns are defended and C5
followed by A4 that starts to look like
it's more fun for black despite the
structure all right the aesthetic is off
but the pawns can push so Bishop C5
maybe Rook B5 please trade me on B4 that
gives me a pass Pawn but that also gives
white some chances to get active
yeah it's exactly right
I'm exactly right now black cannot take
on C5 here
just in case anyone is confused no way
just to show how bad that is what is it
oh it's only Plus
0.5 it looks so bad yeah playing chess
with an eval bar is just it just kills
the the instructive value because the
beginner will be like no coach you're
stupid it's 0.5 but no no GM will play
Bishop takes C5 in that position long
term you have nothing look they're
calling the cops outside I don't know if
you can hear that literally you can hear
cops being called because somebody
considered the move Bishop takes C5
a rook P5 just feels so much more
logical if white ever takes there goes
this pawn and now black is better and it
seems very clear because you have an
advanced pass Pawn so Rook B5 is in fact
Fabiano's move and only after this Pawn
goes to D4 would I calculate Bishop
takes C5 I do not want to give all
activity to white but now if we okay I
thought I was doing that I was like I
actually didn't pick up the piece level
you know what that happens when you like
go to show something and then just take
take it out of your hand that's a fob
you're gonna do with Bishop fake C5 yep
now it's a different story because white
does not land a rook there that
will actually just dominate the entire
board right probably got the Rook there
on B5 his King could also slowly walk
over to D6 who is happier here by the
way who's happier in this position
Fabiano because the clock
I see
yeah okay you can trade but rookie and
now he's got an outside pass Pawn with a
rook behind it so if Dimitri is not
careful and this King can enter Then
black has some chances but then you look
and can't enter here can't answer here
if you get into C7 you can't enter there
there's nowhere to go for it and one of
my favorite things to do in a position
like this when I used to teach you know
young young kids it would be how do you
get the white king to F4 and three moves
blows their mind they just don't
understand right the king doesn't have
to move to get to a square sometimes you
can play G4 get the king to F4 and white
can certainly be better but black is
totally still in the race to potentially
get the Rook out from eighth A4 and B3
and A5 A4 and
and there's
still possibilities here for sure
yeah I think it would require some
maneuvering three Bishop D1 Rook D4
blockade the pawn with the bishop
it's a long story and it's not like
black is just gonna allow all that to
happen without gaining some play of his
own so F5 was fabi's Choice he clearly
wants to bring his King close to the
center although
there might be a moment where you regret
bringing your king too far
okay this is this feels Levy like not a
draw offer but an acknowledgment that
the position is just even
whoa is it
is it what are the next few moves so
FG
right HG and then
I I still I still want to play a little
bit I want to move their pieces
I don't want to move my own pieces but
what happens even if the black king gets
to E5 so what
not I play F4
and nothing happens I guess there is
just you're saying the white Rook really
shouldn't move and the BlackRock
shouldn't move and nobody should move
that's what's happening right
and maybe you play Rook A6 try to free
up the bishop but after Rook A6 is
Bishop F1 to kick the oh oh
I actually like that he's
not even taking
that was clever
let me see Bishop Now The Rook is active
and I think then we start slightly
preferring uh Black's position even
though we know it's still an equal one
yeah if black has an option to just do
this actively then
this game will end much faster but so I
guess now with Bishop B3
I don't know I don't know I guess black
is not going to play Bishop B3
I'm just gonna
well Fabi can draw if these pawns come
off the board and we take the Bishops
off as well but even without that would
be a draw right rook and three pawns
these three versus rook and two pawns
those two that is a theoretical draw and
quite an easy one for carwana
yeah Fabi has four pawns none of which
work together at all but the benefit and
this just shows the inherent asset of
having an outside pass Pawn in this
whole world of end games cannot be
understated the pawn on A5 is the only
reason Fabi is not just clearly worse
it's because once it starts running it's
almost impossible to stop
and that's what's making this kind of a
mutually Frozen position I'm very
curious to see what happens in the rest
of this match because it really does
feel like thus far it's been fobby
and
yeah that first game he was so close but
good defensive effort from Dimitri
I think we could potentially see a sort
of liquidation here like if you go
rookie sorry Bishop C6 Rook C8 take take
here this is the kind of draw I was
mentioning right theoretically this is
quite simple for black especially for
someone of Fabiano's caliber and
expertise so he does in fact Play Bishop
to B3 and we'll see if all this happens
and then they'll Shuffle around a bunch
but Levy
I know we're jumping ahead a little bit
what opening should on Drake and play or
what even first move in response to
karwana's E4
well that's a good question
I think you should play E5
but if he doesn't trust some of the prep
that he plays then I don't know
I don't know he certainly should not
play the French again
so
I don't know Robert maybe a sicilian but
that's the thing is he doesn't need to
win with black just needs to stabilize
so I think I think E5 is
I think E5 is quite solid it's
definitely the way to go
yeah I don't think he should repeat the
French
although speaking of repeating oh what
no Fabiana didn't want to repeat he
could have played Bishop B3 there yeah
look at fobby
alpha male and she's like yeah who you
who you think is repeating moves here
Bobby's actually trying to play for when
Bobby gives a smile stretches look at
that
okay does he want to play King D7 to
defend this pawn and then play Bishop B3
in A4 that way C6 defended
perhaps that's what he has in mind
there's F6
never play that move
yeah unless it's for it unless it's to
kick an active King out of your
territory then you probably should
consider it is there Rook G8 here that's
what I was wondering
probably not just Bishop takes C6 I feel
like yeah I feel like that's but maybe
and if white has to play F3 or something
it could be annoying but
I was going for a cheapo but that's
exactly what I was going for like Rook
G8 F3 I take
and then check you and even all of this
doesn't work somehow somehow like the
whole point everybody's F5 and that's
the pain and that would be enough but
you can just move uh your Pawn up and
then after it takes take on A5 and it's
a draw because Black's pawns are so bad
so even if you win a pawn you're not
winning the game
yeah that's the thing about Rook end
games and Bishop end games you're like I
want a pawn it doesn't matter because
white sea Pawn is so strong if it gets
through
wow this is like is are we just getting
a bunch of teasing here but actually No
One's Gonna Play for a win because I'm
getting really excited that somebody's
gonna lose this game I think five
minutes playing for a loss now his weak
pawns are a serious issue Rook F4 can
happen uh this Pawn A5 is not going
anywhere with the King
so close to the a file and Rook D4 to D6
looks very scary with a double attack
and on Drake and suddenly has more time
Levy
he does oh but it's it's super close
only thing I was gonna say is fabi's
playing like a guy who has a three
minute time Advantage if Bobby's playing
like a guy who if you look at White's
clocks like oh 115 black has four
minutes no fabies it's a minute on the
clock this is absolutely a gamble but I
guess he's doing it in a calculated
fashion understanding that okay I can
play on but there's not a substantial
amount of risk problem is you do this
until you're down to 20 seconds
and suddenly it feels completely
different to play the way they're
playing so we're about to see right now
well apparently white is much better
right but why why is it much better is
that because at some moment
you just Target these Pawns
Good Start I think there could be an F4
and like a rook
over to H2 maneuver
that's kind of what you need
yeah wow another F4 remember last game
F4 was this it was it was a game changer
now you have F4 again and then rotating
The Rook around all right there's Rook
F4 Robert I think someone's gonna lose
I think it's me Fabiano although he is
up 20 plus seconds on the clock that's
huge for his chance to survive because
Bishop A4 apparently Incorrect and
imprecise choice don't play F5 here huge
blunder because the E4 do not try to
trade pawns you know right here there's
a pin in a position
this is now showing why it's so hard to
play with four Pawn Islands in an end
game
especially the further apart they are
because the Rook behind the pond here
for black is just it's just misery every
white piece is doing something having
said that white doesn't actually have a
way to attack anything just yet
the time is ticking I just mentioned
this is going to get really dangerous
with 20 30 seconds on the clock Rook B8
wow
wow do you have to go back to C3 here
well there is the threat of rugby whoa
oh G4 is hanging I'm like what's he
doing oh are you just trying to trade
everything off with G4 so well timed he
there might have been one or two moves
there for Andrea and he missed it look
at that he played King C3 preventing
Rook before what happens Rook B4
and that's a good night
and maybe a shot D1 but how you can't
win this dude two pawns for black take
care of business over here and then
you're still listen but King B he wants
to get his King over here
feel like it's never quite over
admittedly four Pawn islands are going
to be much easier to defend when there's
nothing to attack them
so there's a lack of offense is there
any defense or is defense just uh just a
reflection of offense I don't know when
I get into too philosophical here it
doesn't look like there's much the
bishop on D1 has to guard the a pawn Wow
if G5 you probably lose his weight so he
goes can you bet with another two
separate Pawns
you be careful
before whoa
he didn't trade he goes to push this
Pawn so how does kick Bishop C4 to B5 is
he in time
yeah wow I don't know
18 seconds ships
D7 you want Josh D5 maybe Daniel in the
chat saying he's happy he's not either
player he just gets to observe F5 is a
nice move that cage there built for the
king unable to get in Bishop D5 might
just get to a mutual stalemate oh but oh
wow F4 nice move but if King G1 is
Bishop F3 always available to go after
this G4 plus he goes Bishop E4 to stop
any g-pawn moves Bishop F3 now
yeah Force pump is not Bishop E4 back
and
oh he's just gonna lose a pawn
wait takes C6 oh cc6 okay
so why would you do that but now that
no more pieces remain
yeah there's not enough here and let's
not forget the a pawn existing with the
bishop on the board is still a draw if
the white king gets to the corner wait
why is he like his Pawn go oh my gosh
Bishop five check he's Bishop B5 check
it's huge yep
oh oh
Fabiano completely blundered in a
drinking spots it instantly
this is over
oh and C8 he doesn't even have to check
him he does it this way oh my goodness
this is game over yeah forces of Queen
trade
I am in shock Robert Robert I literally
said that was what was that was what was
bound to happen you play with fire five
seconds on the clock there is a chance
you get burned and Dimitri and draken
just stuck doesn't just save this game
he wins this game against Fabiano
caruana fabina caruana has been worse
for precisely five game five moves
excuse me of this match and it was the
final five moves of this game he
blunders he loses this one I can't
believe it let's go to that moment very
quickly here and it was right here after
C7 King G6 was a howler the point
everybody is after Bishop E4 now this
bishop is pinned if you take white gets
to Queen first so that was a
ridiculously bad oversight from one of
the best players in chess history
walking right into the only idea
available you can just trade pieces
start bringing your king over I mean
there's so many ways to hold this game
he found the one way not to that's
actually shocking yeah he just doesn't
have to put his King and Bishop on the
same line he could just do anything
because he just moves Bishop back yeah
because if white ever Queens then King
G6 later you sacrifice your bishop and
King G6 white cannot get to you in time
that's unbelievable in fact you're
actually just winning obviously in some
cases wow
that is an absolute shocker Levy the
players I think they need a little bit
of a break we are going to take one as
well because we need to head on out of
here for a few we'll set things right
back up but just want to give another
shout out to Brave for being the
presenting sponsor so we'll be right
back for more from the chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to the 2022
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave Grand Master Robert Hess
alongside International Master Levy
Rosman Levy we just saw Fabiano caruana
hand that game over to Dimitri on draken
so will the American be able to bounce
back in this match and secure his place
in the round of eight in Toronto
I have absolutely no idea those were two
of the most shocking
defensive efforts and then ultimately I
don't know if you can really call them
swindles it's not the Swindle is
generally when you go from completely
lost to completely winning with some
tricks and dragon just plays the game
and he manages his time well and so far
he's managed his nerves well also and
he's up one and a half to have when you
know maybe he would be wouldn't be
otherwise so I guess we're gonna take a
look at our our bracket here overall to
preview what we're really
looking at in the in our matchups today
Robert
yeah well the winner of the car one on
drinking match plays Wesley so Wesley
waits for a really tough opponent in the
next one and Nakamura and Dominguez they
whoever wins this one will face the
winner of Judah and Serana so no easy
customers in the global championship
Levy it's uh two games remain here one
half half is the lead for Nakamura and
on draken we have two matchups that are
uh one and a half to half and this is it
this is the last matchup that is going
to be
basically online right I mean we're
we're sending folks to this amazing kind
of live Esports final style matchup in
Toronto and okay Cara's looking around
very confused
I don't know what he's because the car
just had black
oh we need to fix the colors here linear
just had the white pieces so we this
game will be ended there it goes game is
aborted so oh linear has to get the
black pieces this time around ah yes
that is that that is important Robert
and I just for the record we we are not
the one star Robert why'd you start the
game with the wrong color man
oh come on you had one job
geez
well linear has one job here and it's to
not lose this game because if he loses
he is eliminated from the cgc instead of
the Queen's game accepted we got the
Queen's Gambit declined and you'll
notice a big difference in the qga black
takes this pawn and hands over the
center now it's a position where the
Bishops are free to roam this Pawn on D5
takes control over Central squares and
Levy I think ultimately a pretty decent
Choice from Lanier who is well versed in
so many different opening lines
absolutely but also kind of strange
nowadays you are not seeing the top
players play a Queen's Gambit decline
move order it's very much popular at
intermediate Advanced Master Level of
the game but folks are going to play D4
Knight F6 C4 E6 rather than putting the
Pawns in the center first there's just
certain nuances like the nimso Indian
but I actually think that Lanier did not
want to do that he did not want to play
into an IM so and we have a exchange
ragozan right is what we have we it's
technically what this is and Hikaru
playing Knight F3 which is also kind of
a rare move order and do you think
linear is going to play G5 and Knight E4
like my midiar of wood if you gave him
this position no he doesn't Castle you
could still do this even after castling
and mamajarov is certainly one of the
players who choose the five minute
caruana has played the black side of a
position just like this against
mamajarov so these positions can get
very very sharp and once again Hikaru
Nakamura down on time in the opening and
he's played perfectly in the first two
games he has been stellar and as soon as
I say perfectly he makes an imperfect
move
yeah wow he plays Knight D2 right away
why is that imperfect C5 I think just
something just strike right the Knight
and F3 and the Queen on D1 we're
protecting the D4 Square
C5 is an idea you want to play
regardless so play Knight D2 feels like
you are welcoming that pawn push Knight
D2 breaks every opening principle in
existence it it he's moving backwards in
the opening he's moved that night
already he's not developing toward the
center he's removing the defense of the
center Pawn did Hikaru mix up his lines
here is that what happened like did he
maybe he was supposed to play Knight D2
in a slightly different move order or is
his engine prep just better than
whatever we're offering like is has he
analyzed this in the cloud and to a much
higher depth because why didn't he just
play like A3 or E3 I'm so confused
I clicked the open Explorer and there's
only one game that I can see where black
in this position played C6 rather than
C5 so I don't think this was some kind
of a known prep maybe he's coming up
with Novelties and things like that but
it's just based on time consumption I
think he just was kind of making a move
to stop 94 these g594 ideas but C5 is
just asking begging to be played here as
you're pointing out the night moved a
second time no control over D4 so C5 and
if you decide to take something like
this already looks very unpleasant for
the white king
yeah I'm I'm so perplexed I I I'm also
gonna try Knight D2 has literally never
been played
like the movie three has been played in
about 99 of the games there and if you
don't play E3 in that position with the
Knight on F3 You're Gonna Play Queen C2
oh man
yeah he car was looking around like
wait what happened maybe his idea was
c5a3 could that have been his idea
because that actually doesn't look
ridiculous right because you you want to
after Knight D2 play c583 somehow and
but maybe that position is just bad for
white I don't know how
but somehow
black could consider taking on D4 and C3
black can take out C3 right away and
hand white a questionable Pawn structure
over there uh but we are about to get
the third game between five and a Corona
and Dimitri on Drake and underway A3 was
in fact hikara's Choice we'll see what
linear chooses as a reply but Fabiano
needs to take this game Levy he lost
game two there and another French
foreign wow
wow in a knight C6 French
oh my God this is
this is shocking this is uh
this is not this is not okay Robert what
there's kids watching what are we
looking at for all the chess Learners
and students out there listen to your
coaches to meet you on Drake and I'm
sure is a brilliant coach in his own
right but he is playing something
against five minute carwana that he
looked at that he's come prepared with
in this individual game no he didn't
play this line in game one it is very
cramped for black white has these great
central control this bishop on C6 is
hardly a bishop at all right it is kind
of locked in hemmed in by its own pawns
so white has the initial Edge but what
a dragon hopes to rely on is the fact
that the position will remain closed for
a while he can complete his development
and only then counter in the center and
try to get creative and get some counter
play of his own
you gotta respect the way Andrea can
plays chess though
he just doesn't care like you really he
just he absolutely doesn't care I was
not expecting that he would show up with
theoretical lines today but I also was
complete nonsense lines like and the
thing is the top level players have
played this but it's so rare when you
play something like .05 of the time that
in terms of popularity just asking for
trouble but he almost feels like he has
a free pass right because he's up just
straight up up but Robert I don't know
if you agree with me he could keep
playing like this for a bit and it might
work in the last like few moments of the
game but uh
I feel like this is just giving Fabi a
chance to tie the match
well I love the feature chat we have
here imagine how well Dimitri would be
doing if he got a good position of the
opening I mean it's like it's like
literally plus two in the first time
moves
yeah it's not good I mean that much is
clear right there is a space is white
for the taking this Knight on E2 is
going to go to F4 he plays B3 so he can
play A4 and expand on the uh Queen side
as well and if black is left with his
light score bishop and white has a
knight I mean that's just the worst
possible scenario so right E7 this
wasn't a gameard right this was Knight
C3 Knight C6 Knight C3 Knight C6 it
doesn't even have a name I think this
opening literally doesn't have a name
it's just it
on my screen it says French defense
normal variation though there's nothing
normal about this to my eyes no no so
chess.com just defaults to calling
something normal out of respect this is
absolutely abnormal
and it only says normal for the super
jams who play it but when you know
everyone at chat plays it it's like the
questionable variation don't do this
variation yeah exactly I I think
theories just straight up goes out the
window here there's no there's nothing
there's absolutely nothing wow well
someone in chat could
make history play this a lot have
success late in the candidates we'll
name it after you
it's a great piece in C6 love that one
yep so good
the position
you're near losing I know we're being
harsh but when Levy and I dissect this
we're looking at the quality of the
pieces the potential of the pieces and
by playing Knight F4 what Fabiano has
just done is he's almost permanently
prevented the move Pawn takes E5 because
what you can't afford to do is give a
piece the E5 Square in a particular
Knight because if white ever took on F6
the pawn takes back covering E5 if you
take on E5 first goes Knight G6 then
goes 95 and this Knight is just a
brilliant piece here where you have
problems all across your dark squares
and the pawn structure is ridiculously
bad
yeah and if you take on C6 here by the
way for the record you will probably be
arrested so please do not take the
bishop on C6 here uh
you're not going after this bishop
that's for sure
Advantage it's so comment in the chat
that said Hikaru was better
so
I don't know how that happened we should
go take a look
okay we will leave Dimitri with this
really nice looking position and well
what happened was after A3 the bishop
dropped back to A5 which apparently was
not the best choice from Lanier he
should have taken on D4
taking on C3 and then entered a position
like this which is odd you don't get
this very often but maybe once again you
take advantage of the knight in Queens
place in Levy and strike in the center
yeah it looks like D4 was the critical
move there sort of calling calling the
uh the bluff and yeah after D4 or what
is even White's move
I mean the computer says Knight B1 like
it doesn't it doesn't strike me as good
preparation I mean it's I don't know I
have maybe maybe I just don't know
anything about Chess well 94 would be a
better version but G5 is the counter
punch stopping the pan attacking the
bishop and if this is your best option
next thing is gonna happen is Black's
gonna take this pawn and bye bye
was this a bluff or did he not actually
I don't know like did he plant the
something that he had prepared and he
had a feeling Lanier would not play the
most critical line or did he just mix up
his lines and got a little lucky I don't
know we will never know
we'll never know I feel like lucky is
the answer here because the line doesn't
look very good knight D2 there are
positions where you do that but usually
the queen is on C2 first so I think he
mixed up a variation and this just so
happens that it's paying off for him
yeah I mean there's still plenty of life
here there's still a lot to play for it
is anything but equal the last couple of
games it sort of felt like
here if yukaro have this pawn and if you
survive maybe you draw a win and this
game is anything but that this game is
in Balance Bishop pair isolated Pawn for
black broken structure for white lots to
play for and as you said if Hikaru wins
this game that's it Lanier does not get
another chance
well Leonard going after the C5 Pawn
stopping Bishop D6 because the Knight
can now capture it here so that was a
pretty big moment and I think white just
develops E3
your palm structure is great and this
Pawn doesn't go
as hard as I try the Pawn's not going
back to G7 what's wrong with Queen D4
just for now making it annoying to take
back
also looks very good
and then E3 maybe and also if if I get
to play E3 with white I would not
hesitate to take your knight on A6
and then all of a sudden the C Pawn is
moving it looks like the world's dumbest
move and you almost never play a move
like that but in this case it's actually
a great move I think
no
I'm with it Queen D4 looks
energetic protecting your Pawn that's
under attack twice and only defend it
once so Queen D4 looks
very very reasonable maybe just a queen
E7 and
give up D5 to win C5 because white has
no development on the king side uh so
and he hey
lovey
yeah but the evil hates it but you've
been you've been talking to Hikaru I
mean prepping oh no no I would not
poison his mind before a game a very
important match like this and now what I
like to I like to play the game of why
do stockfish hate my move
I don't know H5 F5 something aggressive
or is it something more solid
I was like Queen E7 but they're all
oftentimes you also play B6 just to give
away a pawn but get the activity so for
instance B6 takes takes E3 then this
Knight comes into C5 and all of a sudden
black is creating threats you might fix
your Pawn structure with Pawn take C5
that would kick the queen away it feels
like black is the one gaining Tempe here
and white is just reacting to Black's
threats he didn't play B6 he played my
first instant Queen E7 uh which okay I
guess not quite as strong as B6 but
still looks reasonable there's also
something that white would love to play
here which is F3 if possible and Force
black to take the bishop after which the
H file just looks super super appealing
but black is going to take on C5 black
is not going to take the bishop
for sure C5 now is under attack enough
times so yeah I think this is still
looking nice for Hikaru F3 looks like a
reasonable Choice even if Knight C5 you
start trading pieces you do have the
pair of Bishops uh and Black's King will
remain open so I think we should maybe
leave Hikaru for the moment and look at
what's happening The Other Board because
there have been some pretty significant
changes Levy Black's pawns are storming
down the king side or at least they're
trying to but white has maximum control
over the F4 square and many of the other
dark squares
Dimitri just loves playing positions
where his all his pawns are on light
squares when he plays Black in this game
he has all his pawns still on the board
and seven out of eight of them once
again
are on light squares man that Bishop on
C6 just doesn't enjoy life and yet the
evaluation is equal
apparently somehow
only the chess Gods know how but somehow
I think somehow is doing nothing it's
one of these positions where black just
shuffles because some people would play
H4 H3 very quickly and I I don't think
that's actually the right way to go
because white simply responds with G3
and then we'll later have this F3 move
to pry open the position so you don't
want to send your Pawn down to H3 where
later in the game it will be a Target
overextended and thus I think it makes
more sense to just simply Shuffle what
is White's plan here you might want to
play B4 that drops the A4 Pawn so how do
you do that you play Rook A2 Rook A1
like Dimitri did in game one remember
that Levy those ugly Rooks in the H file
and then try to push but it takes
forever
yeah it does and listen if Dimitri can
get away with this against Fabiano
what can you really say right
it's just
like Bobby's biggest strength
he's even getting a head start
and he's still unable to to punish
Dimitri to the full extent of the chess
law if you will
Dimitri just kind of plays around and
until Fabiano actually dominates from
start to finish and puts the game away
without any doubt toward the end Dimitri
will continue to play like this and this
is Fabiano's last game with white
obviously we might have an Armageddon
but so it's a it's a very tense spot in
this match
yeah and the main thing here is the side
that controls the pawn brakes is often
the side with the advantage now having a
knight in a closed position is good but
the Knight has nowhere to jump to the
bishop covers C5 if you play C4 that's a
pawn break but you also break open the
diagonal for the bishop you that'll
likely backfire and cause white a ton of
problems so it's not actually clear how
white proceeds it might need to be
slower a methodical approach maybe like
I was mentioning Rook here Rook here C3
slow maneuvering and black doesn't have
anything to do of his own so on Jake
will be forced there's no other choice
but to shuffle
yeah and it's up to Fabi well it will
there be a way is there a way to play
something like Queen A5 B4 B5 that looks
winning by the way those three moves
together they just look like they win uh
so what do you what do you play
what do you have wait is there
wait can you put this on the word Queen
A5 uh okay please queen queen C3 uh
Robert I was gonna say queen A5
uh H4 B4
B6 and it's a draw
like well you have I thought black can
like repeat moves Bishop B7 and Bishop
C6 oh there's Queen A7 oh there's Queen
A7 and I guess somehow you're you don't
get trapped like Queen C6 King D7 wow
well that's this I exactly know exactly
mean King B8 B4 and then B6 that's what
you're looking for yeah yeah there you
go yeah just both sides have to go back
and forth and that's just to draw so the
king taking away A7 is important yeah no
that's something to keep an eye on and
um
yeah Dimitri's Bishop on the white
square is going to be an additional Pawn
that's true it is a big Pawn over there
and first 500 plays Queen C3 Levy I
ultimately think that Fabio needs to
pressure Dimitri on the clock make moves
like Rook F to B1 and just
pretend to threaten things there's no
attack for black G3 is not a threat
white has all of his pieces carved in
the Square H3 is met by G3 so it's time
to
pretend to threaten things does white
want Bishop C1 Bishop A3 who wants a
trait of dark scored Bishops here
I just don't I don't like it allows G3
but I see the Merit that you try to gain
squares for your knight if the dark
squid Bishops vanish right now and white
played Knight F4 and G3 white would
probably just be positionally winning
it's like as long as you don't get mated
uh I think when people are saying hey
Carlos game is crazy let's go see what's
going on
let's go back to Hikaru Nakamura versus
Leno Dominguez Hikaru trying to punch
his ticket to Toronto we know how much
he loves Canada in particular Vancouver
and what in the world there is a king on
F2
what is this Pawn structure let's just
go back yeah where we left off it was
right here and he went H4 so we got
Ultra aggressive the engine does not
like the move because of exactly what
linear did he said you are going to have
some really bad pawns on the C file on
the G file and is this worth being up a
pawn for Levy I starting like Black's
position yeah I wonder is the is one of
the best moves here for black to play G4
like what is the top engine move here to
just shut down the white position
completely or is it just to play Bishop
F5 and get as much development as fast
as possible so Bishop F5 is the second
best the best move of course B6 Knight
B8
[Laughter]
all right I mean shut up not you all
right there you go
Bishop of five is like the most
reasonable move ever uh Knight B8 trying
to go to C6 yeah I see why that's a good
idea but come on
yeah yeah
night night B8 is uh
no and I was I was gonna make a joke in
line with recent events you know current
events in the world of shows but we're
going to stay away from inappropriate
humor Bishop of five is much more
natural move and after that Knight C7 96
Knight B8 Knight C6 looks much more
natural when the bishop has at least
moved or The Rook has moved
yeah the other night maneuver makes
perfect sense as well and now we're even
on the clock so E3 played going after
this Knight I feel like now Knight B8 is
even more logical because the knight's
under attack
yes
and uh that that ensuing endgame with
black potentially having all the pawns
broken apart is not very appealing or
maybe it is maybe Lanier just
understands just at a far higher level
level than I possibly could but
I don't know how much I like Bishop
takes A6 for for black the more that I'm
thinking about it Robert I actually
don't think he has to play Knight B8 but
I don't know
you know what he should do is play this
one of these moves pretty quickly
because he knows Knight C7 is a
reasonable move he's just and he played
it after 40 something seconds that's a
move he could have played in 15 seconds
and that is what has been his biggest
weakness in the match is his time
consumption even when he's been well
ahead in the clock he allows hikara to
get right back into it by burning clock
at inopportune moments and 96 is a
threat this king is out in the open on
F2
I feel like linear has good chances if
he can maintain the speed
yeah but it's such a tense position
white is going to play
exactly Queen F4
I don't know 96. I'm bringing that
Knight right into the game
you are yeah
it's linear though he has to go 96.
yeah nothing else right it doesn't
really also white is threatening Rook
takes H6 by the way
for sure that's a hanging Pawn
yeah 96
makes a lot of sense you could even take
back on G5 with the pawn and go after
the C5 Pawn right that's a Sitting Duck
that's going to be captured once this
Rook gets to C8 so I feel like linear is
in good shape for the moment if he plays
Knight D6 there it is and maybe he can
play for more meanwhile
um if we can we will just show you
what's happening on the other board
there have been some trades and now it's
opposite colored Bishops here and
what if black does nothing what if like
just moves back and forth maybe he
brings this King to H5 just for funsies
what is White's plan Fabi is doing his
kind of patented headshake he
doesn't like what's transpired he needs
to find something
and if the queen side locks up there
there ain't nothing he can do
and draken has one of the strangest top
level playing Styles I have ever seen
he's like he's kind of like report but
he's almost even even more absurd
because he's so clutch As Time ticks
lower
and so sharp and so defensively gifted
is a nightmare matchup you can never put
him away it feels like
he is really a solid player I mean
unspectacular opening play a very
limited access to squares but he doesn't
mind he is happy to keep shuffling and
Rook D2 played made Rook D3 Rook C3 I
just don't know where white ultimately
is going but I see that Black's Kings on
G6 likely going over to H5
yeah
I'm going to you could put anything you
want on H5 Rook King
oh King F1 right we both we all right
you want to walk your king I'm gonna
mock my king too
King's going to B2 the Petrosian King
march and it's a good time to do it
because black has no active play uh the
bishop 104 just happens to look a little
bit better than the bishop once he's
sick oh I I don't think I like that move
yeah me neither
yeah I was gonna say black and play B7
to B6 right and defend but
why no need for that can you feel like
Queen C3 I know Queen B4 is available
but I'm not even sold at the queen trade
is that easy for black because now you
have a pawn sticking out on B4 ah maybe
you have C3 after all that
um just open the C file yes
and then you can even maybe consider
sacking on C6 and just play like rook
and Bishop with the past Pawn on the
queen side long long long term thinking
long into the future but
I feel like Robert every time we try to
predict something Andre can just comes
up with some odd or refutation of our
idea just some super creative wow Fabi
doesn't play Queen C3 I think Fabi is
not having a fun time dealing with these
with these openings and it's it's making
him almost hesitate look at this King D1
wow and I can't I'm drinking suddenly
decide to go for activity like with the
C5 break of his own oh yeah yeah you
gotta feel for five because he's like
running his King over there and the
action's about to happen
it's actually gonna commit C5 you've
committed just go and then play F3 like
yes C5 is gonna open up whites King but
F3 will open up Black's King and if
you're fobby look at the clock you're
now down a minute and 20 seconds and
it's Gonna Keep ticking if you don't
start making these decisions almost
impulsively like you got to use your
intuition and run your king and push
your pawns and open up the black king so
let's leave Fabiano to
his King marched because the other game
has uh changed a little bit we just
check in to see how Hikaru and linear
are doing so look at that eval bar
Advantage Dominguez yeah Advantage
Dominguez we'll see if he's able to
consolidate but it's a very tactical
position right he's got to be super
sharp with this calculation
um remember how we saw that position
where Fabiano had pawns that look like
this
yes
and Knight takes D4 apparently not the
most precise but how can you blame
Dominguez for that capture
gotta take it back yeah what was what
was
the move there
was probably something absurd as usual
yeah maybe just like a knight C5 just
like go for the squares yeah I was gonna
say it's probably something like that
just keeping the tension but he he he
forced the issue and
he takes improving the structure there
very nice from Hikaru
what about Rook C8 here
because if takes Rook takes B7 you just
get your Rooks
super quickly into the game
yeah that actually does look super
annoying I think hikara will make him
take with the pawn to keep things closed
but the bishop on G6 is also a Savage
you're never getting rid of that oh look
there it is
like
he's got a yeah he's got a trade now I
think
I think it's rookie one Dominguez like
you know you're saying a car needs a
trade lender says no trades for you I'm
Gonna Keep as many pieces on the board
because I'm going to try to pick off
your targets your weaknesses and the
King on F2 might find something danger
especially if this bishop can plant
itself on e4 then I'm gonna go Rook E3
and Bishop D3 the second you take on C6
ah okay I'm gonna show that just quickly
because Levy's making the point that I'm
just gonna try to close the position up
he says and maybe black is symbolically
better better Pawn structure but there
is good defense everywhere for white not
enough pawns remain so I don't know but
I'm sure computer has some more active
way to deal with all this like rookie
five I don't know or something rookie
one sure
sure but I think your point is well
taken I mean seriously this trading off
the Bishops will ease the uh drawing
path because if you've got Bishop E4 and
like F5 in that long-term danger for the
white king
okay it does it this way I I like the
idea of Rook ad1 after so Rook H to E1
and Rook a to D1 and trading on D3 and
that that regard so that at least both
Rooks are in the middle I'm actually
kind of confused he did it this way but
I'm sure he has some sort of plan
I don't know actually of course out of
one minute by the way yeah he looks
unhappy so I don't know what he
overlooked but I guess the other way was
better rookie q1 and then Rook 81.
but but Lanier finally he's the one
putting pressure on the clock I mean
he's been had he said the lead on time
for most of the match he just then Burns
clock at the wrong moment look at this
40 seconds remaining for a carpets
rookie five that was an inaccuracy B
takes C6 is automatic hitting the bishop
is it what about F6 was there F6
there's F6 now yeah there's F6 now but I
thought maybe there was some sort of
tactic yeah this is really strange he's
not trading the bishop he's going to
lose a lot of time here
and linear might also play like Rook B8
rugby three okay see that Levy it may
not have been the 100 best move although
he's keeping the advantage he's doing it
quickly and he understands that the way
to beat Hikaru is both on the board and
not giving him the time to be
resourceful
yeah I almost feel like with Hikaru the
time that takes lower his adrenaline
kicks in and when you have to make one
move in one second when you're nervous
he you gotta pick Hikaru right it's
either Hikaru or Magnus like their
nerves are or I mean today it's on
draken but those two guys and the
problem is he's not gonna go down
without a fight you got to beat him like
10 times in one game
like this looks miserable for white but
it's not lost
no and hikar might do this at some point
just to try to get a mating net of sorts
G4 G5 Rook E8 Rook h8
and what can black do to stop it because
if Rook takes A3 just G5
oh there's always Bishop H7 the end to
save the day so maybe lender can go Pawn
grabbing just take this one go after C3
have an outside pass Bond
big moment here for doing this
it's a good point start with King G7 the
A3 Pawn is not going anywhere so King G7
feels like a completely reasonable uh
first step at this point he takes an A3
we spend a lot of time doing it King G7
G5 here her car goes
I I think after Rook h8 it's always
Bishop H7 right oh for this bishop D3
yeah yeah sorry I mean for sure this
Rook is immediately under attack and he
plays F6 he listens to Levy
I don't have that answer they're all
about you know 0.3 minus 0.3 we're
hovering in territory where most moves
should be uh decent but I like Lanier's
clock he's putting pressure on him
A5 just just send it
your King's not getting mated on F6
you've done everything right send the
pawn
why is he thinking for so long
Lanier you gotta go man
you gotta go
and thank you for the raid from both tez
live
here that that's coming in so appreciate
that one and well we appreciate these
this end game we have in front of us as
well Rook E7 was Leonard dominguez's
Choice trying to get the Rooks off and
then use the outside pass pawn and
attack the C3 Pawn as well so
if Rook H6 good defense by Hikaru Robert
I'm back I am back hey some people would
have celebrated that my microphone cut
out but unfortunately for those people
uh we are back and better than ever and
Hikaru is down to 10 seconds
oh 10 seconds Bishop h a great move just
trading off pieces if you swap as a rook
see through this Rook H7 check and then
Rook takes ASAP but the king Levy this
King goes to D6 and D4 is a bit of a
problem D6 or E4 King F5 King E4 also
possible over the rookie seven just cut
you off
wow ah the pro the problem is if Rook
Dita is Rook A4
you just gotta defend passively E6
and then Ah that's smart we're okay four
after you forced the king to defend the
pawn
yeah the king doesn't get to venture out
into the center like you were advocating
for
amazing and that's it this this was
linear's chance
it came and it went and he will have to
rely on game number four he's gonna have
to bring something to the table
foreign
and come up with
some better way of playing against the
Berlin
because that other way was probably the
best that he was going to provide and
Hikaru still defended in excellent
Manner and there you go we see this
typical simplification down to a
position of
one pawn and balanced end games uh
beginners intermediates watching you
gotta know how to defend this hey you
fill it or position down
and you'll be good to go
and what black wants is to get this King
into C4 very quickly but a car will not
allow that because this King got up the
board that would be an issue but white
can always give it a check
Hikaru really does not look excited for
a guy that is going into the knockout
game of his head-to-head matchup but he
kind of like never looks excited until
the job is done he uh he's frustrated a
bit and he's up on time by the way again
yeah if we're in deep in this end game
here King A3 was also possible King C3
to stay close to your Pawn
yeah
this one's a straw
yeah there's ways to lose with white if
you get to C5 and mate yourself but
I don't think so
nah all of the Rook F3 to D3 to be very
careful now Rook F3 don't go to King B4
although it might still work because
you're Rook G4 but yeah go here because
if the Rook attacks the pawn your king
goes up yeah Rook
cannot get to this D4 Pawn
that's
gonna get some more moves I don't think
Lanier is going to play Rook and pawn
versus
Rook but he will play this position for
sure he might play both
yeah this is it
Hikaru has the ideal setup he knows what
he's doing and he's not gonna allow
Lanier even an ounce of hope so good
game from Dominguez ultimately with the
black pieces he was pressing but for
Hikaru Nakamura 2-1 lead is exactly what
you want at this point let's go back to
carwana against andrekin we have a
minute and a half per side and oh my
goodness this matchup might end right
here revenue of Rook H1 was the last
move played here and it appears that
even material but White's King might be
in worse shape
is it just Rook H1 and queen C4 or what
is it what what exactly is the you can
do that you can also bring the Rook to
C8 your King on B7 is so safe over here
at Queen C4 next this is unbelievable
wow
it's a huge collapse from carwana
and it it was a recipe for disaster from
the beginning he was getting really nice
positions but from that first game
it all went downhill
it just all went downhill and
Israel Community Ford just came over now
It's gotta be right
Queen D7
what
I think this is Dimitri on draken saying
if I draw this game I get white in game
four how are you gonna beat me but that
I mean why not Queen C4 you can never
lose that position
yeah I what I'm so perplexed I'm also a
little bit perplexed why this is such a
bad move but
just Queen D1 yeah Queen D1 or queen A1
right that's the question also do you
have to guard A4 do you have some
Perpetual maybe I don't know
probably what fabi's you know looking at
but how do you not play Queen C4 that is
extremely surprising is there Queen H6
maybe like Queen A4 Queen E6 or do I get
mated can I put my king on C1 or is
there a checkmate at the end with Bishop
D3 it's probably a checkmate at the end
yeah and the black Levy's point is the
black king can always hide on A6 and not
enough checks the queen D1 ultimately
played and now we get a Time Scrabble so
Fabiano gets a new lease on his
tournament by not losing this game at
that moment but Queen H7 still causes
problems probably Queen G1 now
wow keep that Queen out of there
Queen is just desperately different than
Queen H5
oh my gosh this is so scary
and we can see one then
it's King C2 instead
Robert this looks miserable for white
completely agree
no this how do you defend this King B2
good start all right the bishop on C4 is
like the kid who was bullied in grade
school and turned out to be an MMA
fighter
that Bishop was just we made fun of it
the whole game and now it's the best
piece on the board
yeah it's amazing how that happened I
mean to meet you on Drake and just held
steady and now he's impressed he is 30
oh blunder
Queen T1 he's dropping oh check
everything is hanging
that's it
I can't believe it he's just he's gone
down
Queen A1 King D2 and push the pawn just
maybe start getting that one going
wow that is unreal and it was always
bound to happen time got low position
got unpleasant and draken was the
aggressor and I don't think Fabiano's
getting another chance from this point
forward because it's the bishop on F4 is
just a non-factor
Queen E4 check almost works but I think
white is in time to stop the punt
because Bishop B5 he wants A4 A3 why
don't you just play B5 I don't get it he
doesn't want to push his pawns weak in
his King but yeah he's gonna go A4 A3
and then trade Queens yep yep eight
seconds for carwana he doesn't even see
a move here
you should see three played
how was Queen H1 not just winning on the
spot but yeah that's all it is what is
winning was winning
have a
cash push
probably okay Queen not the best move
apparently
he wants his King in
wow wow
there's no Bishop B2 just Queen moves to
B1 right
and queen
although king of six like suddenly what
is Bishop D3 what is he what is going on
in this game oh he allowed to check
but B5 shift D3 back to
oh gosh you want some kind of queen
check
no way seven seconds for andraken
how does he get out of this because
Queen a queen B8 looks like a repetition
so he takes the pawn and now his King
can walk to A5 into B4 it was gonna lose
the A2 Pawn
and then E6 is a target
oh my goodness the b-pawn goes up
yeah Queen B8 and just just yeah the
king is going to zigzag right
mm-hmm
a queen E7
oh my gosh Queen E7 the king would have
gone to C4 into D3
I think this is it we are about to
see the final move
of the matchup between Fabiano caruana
and Dimitri and draken as he punches his
ticket to the round of eight in Toronto
in unreal fashion uh there are matches
and then there are matches and Dimitri
on draken was lights out today he was
not ever going to go down in any of
these three games Robert
unbelievable he was on the edge of
defeat on the precipice and he won uh
game two after drawing game one somehow
and game three he ices the match Dimitri
on draken is an absolute Force I know
people are not as familiar with the name
on draken as they should be but I hope
after the rapid Chess Championship we
got second place and now here in the
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave he is in to the final eight he
will be in Toronto Dimitri on drinking
everybody you will want to write down
that name and not forget it
just a Sublime
Sublime match by him
what did anybody have ondraken beating
karawana in three because that is
exactly what happened in tennis you can
win in straight sets and today we saw
andrekin winning in basically the chess
equivalent with a
magical save in the first game followed
by an even more magical come from behind
victory in game two and this one was a
mildly dubious opening that yes we were
making fun of but we really Robert I
think we both deep down knew that if
Bobby didn't put him away early Dimitri
was going to survive that game because
it seemed like it was going
throughout the entire match and it once
again happened
yeah when you can't land a knockout when
someone is wobbling that's uh gonna let
them back in there you guys just gotta
stay alive Dimitri on Drake and doesn't
just stay alive in the match he advances
to Toronto so if we look at today's
scores uh we see that Dominguez still
has a chance against Nakamura Levy two
and a half for
Dimitri on Drake and incredible
absolutely incredible you can
legitimately make a case that either of
them are deserving to be a one seed
given both of their prowess in all types
of Chess classical rapid and Blitz but
it definitely seems like Dimitri has had
a stellar run in a lot of the chess.com
online events and he's a beast it very
well could be he's the second best rapid
player in Russia right I mean obviously
they have Yandy machine it's a little
bit tough but that's the number one guy
but he's been incredible and he's it
that's it he's not he's enough there's
nothing else besides making it to the
final eight in Toronto and he's
certainly just done that in the most
emphatic of fashions
yeah and it takes a lot of courage to
play that passively against Fabiano
caruana and speaking of Brave well Brave
is our presenting sponsor so we want to
give them a shout out as always because
Brave means private browsing and so much
more by default Brave blocks ads and
trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com chess and with the on Drake
and carwana matchup in the books
demetriundricken heading towards Canada
we do have one game remaining at the
very least between a car Nakamura and
Leno Dominguez here at the 2022
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to anyone
all around the world oh my gosh the
chess.com Global Championship offers the
dream of playing against the best we are
in for a wild ride and hey have we
mentioned there's also a million dollars
at stake the total pot is a million
dollars no that it's not a typo the
prizes our unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remain what a move by Tim Moore
it's over he's gonna lift to tell the
tale and that is enough to take victory
in this Armageddon game Dan yet
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real oh my God massive
congratulations to Sam Savion a trip to
the cgc finals and a clean shot at the
largest first place prize of the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 16. who
will take the next step to Toronto
and return here at the cgc linear
Dominguez looking off in the distance
maybe he's trying to look all the way
towards Canada because if he wants to
make it there he needs to win this game
against Hikaru Nakamura Levy the matchup
between Hikaru and Dominguez lifetime
has been pretty knotted up but right now
hikara with the one game lead
and we basically see in this matchup
exactly why they win and lose more games
in Rapid they have each one a piece in
classical but there is 12 draws as well
and when you go to the rapid at 12
becomes eight wins four losses with one
draw now obviously in their last 10
games has been a little bit closer and
they are quite familiar with one another
but thus far we've seen the differences
in the playing style we've seen the
differences in the approach and it's
been close but Hikaru definitely got the
edge in that first game good opening
preparation shown by both sides good
time management shown by
one of the sides let's put it this way
and we have liftoff I think we're about
to have the game
yeah we are about to have game four
Dominguez gets the white pieces that's
the good news for him uh Hikaru looking
like he doesn't have a worry in the
world he is just focused on this final
game he needs to draw and that puts the
onus squarely on Domingo's shoulder and
we get an Italian so no more Berlin yeah
we get an Italian but the risk of of
changing up your own openings as well is
you you don't know what Hikaru is going
to play Hikaru could have come prepared
with a totally different Italian line he
plays this D6 A6 so he's not he's not
castling yet he's not playing H6 he
moves the bishop to A7
and now he castles so many different
nuances of the move order here and it's
going to be a long battle
anikara has been playing a lot of A5
lines at A6 so I believe he anticipated
that Dominguez would be aiming for that
kind of position and we are 13 moves in
this is still theoretical one of the big
ideas for white is to continue expanding
B5 C4 just get a clamp going Black's
main push is D5 that's not such an easy
move to make work because then the E5
Pawn becomes loose so now Hikaru is the
first player to take a bit of a think he
is trying to figure out what is the
theory here is it D5 I believe that's
too early so a slower move maybe it's
Knight E7 to G6 that way the Knight is
stabilized rather than being able to be
kicked from its current Square
I like The Rook on E6 for black in a lot
of these positions because I I just have
a dream of getting that Knight to F4
after a couple of Moves In The Rook to
G6 but it's never that easy a guy
playing with White's just not gonna let
that happen there's B5 D4 all these
different breaks yeah it seems like
Bishop B2 is the First new move here and
Robert this setup by black is one where
black doesn't ask a whole lot of
questions black just sort of kind of
plays responsive moves whereas in that
A5 line you're much more aggressive but
wow C4 and now the moves are picking up
the pace once again
just give me all of the space says
linear Dominguez and this is a Dominguez
type of position you see him win
beautiful positional masterpieces by
squeezing the pineapple juice out of his
opponent and in this position what is
Black's plan Levy mentioned a night
coming to F4
and then what right this there's just
one night there it's not exactly a
devastating attack so what instead hikar
opts towards C6 and maybe D5 but I mean
linear just doesn't pause
oh Bishop C3
yeah what is this I'm trying to like
follow along
and try to put this game into some sort
of some sort of database and see can you
check the Explorer where where are we
there's been a deform in fact this looks
like the matchup
who was this matchup it was Wesley so in
the previous round not against
um
uh not against Jeffrey Zhang but in his
second round match the round of 32 I
believe he's getting positions like that
or maybe I'm mixing up the players but
there were a bunch of games in a similar
position it was actually the first match
against Dennis lastovich excuse me
yeah there's so much different Theory
and overlapping move orders
um I'm saying somebody there's a course
apparently on this line and uh this is a
fascinating position this is a very
strange e45 game since
black has played A6 and then A5
and lost the pawn you straight up lost
the pawn but he's basically saying I'll
win it back don't worry about it and
look at linear giving up the H Pawn like
you can steal that pawn if you're a hit
card Nakamura but then this Knight comes
to F5 a rook goes to B1 the B7 Pawn is
loose so what a fascinating opening
we've seen thus far and I have to say
that in a must win position Levy this is
linear playing quickly but Black's
position isn't that solid it's actually
a very kind of risky
structure
yeah it is a really risky structure the
B file is super weak you're not going to
get that attack that I was mentioning
earlier with Rook G6 there's no attack
if anybody has an attack here it's white
in the future
very slow Improvement G3 F4 King G2 and
so on maybe Queen G4 somehow I really
like this for white do I like it to the
extent of being able to beat Hikaru
maybe not
maybe not hikaru's been up to the test
defensively today
what we're being told that this is
following David Dominguez beat Nakamura
at in the St Louis rapid and Blitz I'm
not sure it went all the way to this
point because 22 moves deep but from
this variation so linear with happy
memories Nakamura likely with
improvements but Rook B1 Queen F3 Pawn
G3 King G2 Rook H1 Levy your idea it
kind of plays itself in a way and I
don't see where Black's active play is
going to come from
yeah I don't see it either
that and I don't have five is amazing
and I don't have five and e45 games
especially with same side castling is
super scary for black
for sure and that's actually I think
part of the reason why at linear was
okay jettising this Pawn is it
establishes the Knight on F5 and it
can't be kicked because anytime you play
G6 you drop the H6 Pawn but linear after
Queen d8 he goes in the think tank he is
the one who played H4 right here he
didn't have to play H4 he made the move
quickly and these moves are pretty
forced and now he's the one spending
time so his prep I think is finally done
and that's good news for a car and
Nakamura and his fans
that's super scary all of this has been
super scary uh yeah I'm I'm gonna go
I was going and exploring a little bit
what's funny is that this line if you
check the database is all Hikaru
recently
for a super super long period of time uh
Bishop B2 is relatively rare I think
they're actually isn't a Hikaru game in
that line just yet except for that game
between Dominguez and Nakamura and
Robert that game
followed this game until move 19.
wow
when in that previous game Lanier played
B5
but in this game he decided to take the
pawn
that is absurd that Hikaru played the
exact same way as he did in the St Louis
rapid tournament recently and played the
exact same way again and is like Lanier
I am willing to bet you my prep is
better than your prep
um I'm gonna have to
disagree with that because I'm looking
at this position
and it just looks good for white right
like linear changed one thing he took
the pawn rather than pushing forward and
now the Evo Bar says plus 1.5 I don't
need the Evo bar to explain to me that
this position is nice for white
um this queen he's just gonna venture
out over to the king side uh it feels
like black is quite Frozen in many ways
over here
I just I can't get behind it I agree
I agree B7 looks weak the A7 Bishop is
not doing a whole lot
what just like in any sport sometimes
the team is losing sometimes the player
is losing and you got to play defense
and he's been doing that he's done that
you know he's done that in every game
actually he's demonstrated defense first
it feels like and then defense turns
into offense and he goes on the attack
I guess the big question is how does
white proceed because you're saying
Hikaru at first has to take a defensive
posture and then he's the one who can
move his piece for maybe Knight C5 maybe
Rook G6 things like that so what
actually Is Lanier's plan here he can
bring his Queen out he could also just
play G4 King G2 Rook H1 but that's not a
move you make lightly you need to be
positive that it's the time to do it and
It looks interesting I mean interesting
is a cop-out word I know but it does
look pretty fun it's okay if you say it
with a Russian accent it's like all all
players like that oh no it's very
interesting but yeah so G4 H1 G5 looks
actually very good and if HG Queen H5 is
just game over just straight up win so
uh
do you think the books behind linear are
chess books or regular books
because they match in color
I I feel like it's a collection of some
sort and I
I mean my vision's not that great so I
don't think it's my great predecessors
or anything like that but
it's chess books I think
is it what does that say
I'm trying to look we have a we have a
big big uh capture here of Lanier as
he's thinking
I keep wanting them to put it up on the
big screen you know how many sleuths
there are in the chat I'm not reading
them but I'm sure that they're there
trying to
figure out the titles of the books on
the shelves but I feel like they have to
be at least in part chess books
I would love to ask Lanier strikes me as
a guy who reads
it's just strikes music loves to read
yeah you like to read I love to read
yeah oh
I don't know so I'm jealous oh well I'm
a big reader I was actually looking for
my book but I don't see it somewhere
over there not that I'm giving any
plugs to authors that I'm reading at the
moment anyway but why not I mean when
you're still thinking we could talk
about it
well he's out of book that's clear and
he's trying to oh G3 so slow approach by
Lanier and
now I'm just curious where the books
behind him and now I'm distracted
yeah G3 is such a respectful way of
playing this position just feel like in
a must-win situation you I don't know
you gotta go G4 what was the top engine
move in that position out of curiosity
it was
G4 uh yeah G4 and queen G4 are like
splitting votes essentially uh Queen G4
and then try to move the
move the queen and then play g2g4 well
it's pretty complete G4 though it's
pretty interesting it wants this like
Queen H3 yeah to defend D3 so through
Knight C5 you probably said Bishop B4
and then you can't move the Knight
because there's 97 check kind of stuff
so all sorts of different stuff up here
or apparently not the computer was
trying to change his mind somehow yeah
it's it said that at first and now it
wants like Rook F1 and F4 so I just
wants to go for the attack
ah yeah man G3 is okay he's still going
for this plan but look at Hikaru
rerouting the bishop that's so expertly
done Bishop C5 Bishop f8's passive but
it's the right thing to do the bishop is
at least more valuable on f8 than it is
on A7
still looks awful for black but it's
already an improvement
is white going to try to play F4 I guess
now
you can't take it back with the g-pawn
which what you'd really want but F4 is
the type of move that's begging to be
played in such a position absolutely
not to mention that if the
dark squared Bishop of white was traded
for the Knight
let's say on C5
white would still have a very nice
position with the Knight on F5 but the
bishop on f8 does a great job defending
and A5 falling could spell trouble for
white
yeah
a really big Target that black is trying
to go after he plays F4 right away
because he takes Bishop takes and that
Rook on beat has to move which drops the
B7 Pawn
yeah this is now Hikaru perks up you see
him a little bit there he's like all
right yeah this is what you want to do
you sure about this and Hikaru excels
and stuff like this
counter Play Just understanding the
Dynamics between attack and defense
and linear in a must-win spot is a is a
stressful moment for me because he's
playing an excellent counter-attacker
it's not playing a guy who's just gonna
get a little intimidated by the moment
and
maybe do something wrong but Leonard did
get the exact type of position that he
needs right you're in a must win game
you can't just dilly dally you can say
oh I'm slightly better I'm gonna try to
nurse this little Advantage no he is
going full steam ahead no fear
whatsoever and he has a very good
position with chances to win
yeah but G3 right like he had to go G4
he had to be a bit more disrespectful
about the position
it wasn't
I love how you frame it though he had to
be more disrespectful linear and
disrespect do not belong in the same
sentence ever the guy is simply put the
nicest human being ever
I know and he had to throw that caution
to the wind and play G4 damn it they had
to play G4 G5 Rook H1 all this stuff but
he kind of did a little bit more
respectfully he's trying to do it the
right way but sometimes in chess you
have to not do things the right way
and G4 was an absurd move but
uh I guess not it's not it's not a
stylistic choice for linear
and hikar you know he's
perking up now he's defending quite
where'd he go
stretching
he was touching his toes
what's going on what
is he tying looks like he's tying
something grabbing cables
this is not streaming right now oh that
would be bad
oh man this is mouse dead what is going
on
well hikar back in the day I remember
when we uh playing the Olympiad together
he would type moves on you know all the
way back in the ICC days he'd be typing
moves playing bullet
so oh wow
he's good even without a hardwired mouse
you could just telepathically move
things by looking at them
speaking of what is it is about to
suggest features during Live Events why
don't we get type to move can we do that
somehow
good question I mean guys type to move
please maybe just for Diamond members
I'm a diamond member can we just get it
just for Levy honestly nobody else needs
it yeah you don't like type to move
it just doesn't seem very practical it
doesn't but it you know it's fun
yeah it's exactly oh they're also good
for blindfold chess
very true my blindfold chest you could
just type the moves I don't know just
Food For Thought yeah I don't know he
looked really disheveled there for a
second but now okay time is back to
equal
and
gives a B7 for A5 looks
quite reasonable
Knight C5 okay doesn't want A5 yet
Levy I have to say I think this is
starting to go in hakara's Direction yes
yes yes it sometimes these matchups are
a nightmare stylistically for one of the
sides
and today it really has felt like
sometimes when Hikaru plays Lanier
I almost get the opposite effect like
that day linear is a bit more sharp and
then stylistically it's a disaster of a
matchup for Hikaru like if it ever you
know if your car tries to be a little
bit too aggressive or linear just gets
the kind of position he wants but today
and you're got the positions that he
probably wanted and Hikaru was just
unbeatable he just couldn't be beaten at
all
excellent defense great counter play and
he's doing it for a third game
yeah it looked very promising for linear
and right now uh hikar up a minute on
the clock defending accurately and Rook
B6 I think Knight D7 this Retreat should
be sufficient although there is an
opportunity for linear to sacrifice in
exchange because the Rook is under
attack but you do not want to allow a
white Pawn to land on B6 protected so
Queen B3 is an option here for Lanier
and he's just trying to keep things
spicy
but then Rook A5 I guess you would play
I don't know the night the night covers
B8 very importantly it's a rook B7
Knight C5 walking into but then Rook B8
right what I'm talking about is
something like this Knight survive Rook
B8 and white wins
yeah brutal
yeah oh I I got a fork going on but
rugby it's too powerful uh with the back
rank issues for black
that's so ridiculous Queen B3 is one of
the best moves Rook A5 is the best move
Rook B7 is the best move Knight C5 seems
to be losing
the best move after Rook B7
well if it's not clear then linear
should obviously go for it like you just
gotta trust himself
and yeah two minutes to the car is not
the way to go it top level chess is so
fascinating where you can put a couple
of guys in a certain spot and you know
for a fact that they would play a
certain move like for example Levon
think for a fact we'll play Queen B3 in
that position chakra would play Queen B3
in that position and then other guys
would play Rook B7
I don't know it and then Rook C7 made no
Rook c796 just wins on the spot for
black so
what do you play here what was what was
his plan after rugby seven
he doesn't really have one he could
throw an A6 because you can't take with
the Rook because his Rook b a check uh
check check to the queen or FBA would be
a thread so A6 Knight takes A6 at the
very least you kind of gain a move I
don't know what you're gonna do with
that move but
maybe there's something maybe that maybe
he wanted A6 I don't know something
crazy you know like right but then but
then Knight A6 and then
I don't really know what you're doing
after that he could always go back go
Rook B6 but why would you spend this
much time to just to go backward basics
right yeah and you're in danger of a
repetition I guess there's not quite
there 97 then Queen B3 and you're out of
it he does play A6
do not take this Rook everybody I know a
rook is more valuable than a knight but
not when you give it I wasn't even
trying to make the right move and I did
anyway but you allow this Pawn here it's
attacking The Rook about to promote the
bishop covers the square do not take on
B7 Hikaru does not it takes on A6 so
this is where Lanier needs to just he
needs to go and he plays Queen H5
oh wait a second is Rook takes F7 a
threat
ouch
maybe what's the idea so Knight C5 Rook
F7 will just
oh my the eval's going up here Rook to
B1 switch flanks
oh rugby one is oh and he doesn't
wait a second the car's completely tied
down now yeah I think he kind of
underestimated that and
five and a half minutes is more than
enough time to put this all together
let's let's bring up an analysis for it
because A6 was a clever Try by linear we
liked that move and apparently Knight
takes A6 which is like the most obvious
move is incorrect
um wow the right move I just cheated is
Queen C8 so just kind of keeping
tensional that is an impossible human
move
uh it's possible for a human to play I
should say
Queen C8
all right it's just like you're now
attacking The Rook the A6 spawns the
hanging
um
it allows Rook C7 and stuff but oh
that's that's not happening
yeah
Queen E8 Rook B1
wow
what is is it it's called material
even material it is even material
it doesn't feel like it hasn't felt like
equal material the entire game
well D4 is also hanging for good measure
so it may only be equal material for a
move or two longer I I don't care I'm
not taking that pawn
I don't even notice that pawn is hanging
my knight is only going forward I like
to tell I like to tell uh like low rated
players uh nine times out of ten the
best move was going forward
it's never going back one time out of
ten okay Karo seems to think the pawn is
important he defends it
okay so how does
linear keep going A5 to try to push this
Pawn I like the look of that Rook A7 if
you get the second Rook on B7 you'd be
winning but the Knight will come back to
C5 so you don't get that
this is the moment this is the big
moment of the game linear is better
can he
get it done that's that's it
it's really that's really it can you get
it done or not
he has dropped under five minutes he
card is 646 himself so about a two
minute lead now for Hikaru Queen F3 the
best move like the engine stayed the
same the bar Queen F3 this is just like
profit Lexus right just I'm going to
defend the pawn on D3 in the event of
Knight C5 and then I can go over movies
like Rook to B8 so D3 is a very
important Pawn to keep control of and
tikara is trying to secure control over
B4 so he's maybe trying to put his
Knight there
now Rook B6 is another possibility in
the future to maybe trade the black rook
and but also A4 is hanging now so play
Rook beef Rook one to B5 that way when
Knight B4 happens and oh my gosh linear
is on fire right before the Rook is
inside right The Rook is inside the
where the Knight would be otherwise it
would be blocked out of the action so
now A5 is available Levy this looks so
horrible for black it does it does look
horrible you you missed my punt I know
Nara Dixie likes to hit you with puns R1
B5 ribs
I was wondering why you said ribs I'm
hungry I'm hungry yeah yeah I I I didn't
just blurt out a random word yeah it
rips uh the night before Hikaru is
trying to yes hold it down on the dark
squares but this looks miserable I
completely agree A5 looks very pleasant
Bishop C7 at any moment to secure that
pawn
and linear he just continues to spend a
little bit more time than I'm
comfortable with I mean I'm looking at
the position it's great but it just
doesn't feel like he's found his true
comfort zone
no he hasn't and four minutes goes by
very fast it's like the opposite of
maybe certain other events you can look
at the clock and go oh wow I feel like
it's been five minutes only one ten
seconds right but uh in this case you
look at the clock wait a minute I got 30
seconds left
and somehow time moves faster when you
play Hikaru and okay Rook beat
apparently is wrong
looks great
do you really want to take on ba I don't
think so and Knight C6 back and maybe
that's why look that knight from A6 to
C6
covering A5 now and covering B8
yeah and supposedly he's already
slightly messed it up
how
I mean at some point white has to play
E5 too right you've got to play
E4 E5 maybe A4 A5
that's so crazy that A5 is just not like
winning for white this just doesn't make
any sense
I think it was the right move a few
turns ago when he went Rook to B8 but
A5 with Rook B8 to follow looks very
promising
A5 Knight A5 rugby isn't winning for
white
uh let's easy way to find out
no
all right I don't understand anything
about Chess but Queen D7 there's just
nothing yeah just nothing at all okay oh
allegedly just equal
but well if it's just equal that means
that it's just that it's quite it's a
quagmire nobody can get through
well linear is doing the worst of all
options he's spending a lot of time
he's just too deliberate like you need
to trust yourself and you need to use
the clock as a weapon and right now the
clock is in a huge Advantage for a car
it's why he's staying in this game and
if the time situation were reversed and
the clocks suggested that um Dominguez
could continue to increase the his
chances then we'd be talking about a
different story here but right now Levy
Lanier is just being
too slow
yeah just too slow that's the best way
to describe it Rook B7 I even saw a
stockfish try to flash for a moment
there that black was better which is
completely absurd that's so frustrating
and
it's looking like Queen A8 is on the way
just a fork is that that it
sometimes it's that simple
although moving the queen away from the
King side you might walk into some kind
of Rook takes F7 if you're not careful
there is a queen on F3 after all
yeah there's still scary tactics all
over the board but somehow it's just
it's just nothing there and if black
takes on A4 black gets to the white king
too
amazing defense maybe Rook C7 and after
Queen takes here there's that E5 move
you've been suggesting I think that's
the way to go you need to start going
after this King
I agree Rook c75 he has to do something
how is it possible that hikaru's pieces
have just not gotten air the whole game
and he's still defending he's just
defending everything the Pawn's gone now
black is up a pawn now like I still have
four minutes
wow he's such a tenacious Defender
hezekara Nakamura the guy always puts up
stubborn resistance and he's gonna need
a continued defend you see the
evaluations as zeros now black is up a
pawn so if zeros it means that white has
a great uh set of ideas and chances
against the black king E5 looks like a
step in the right direction and linear
is just spending too much time he's
being a perfectionist perfect is the
enemy of the good he needs to go
perfect is the enemy of the good wow I
have to read more Robert
what a line I hope that wasn't said by
like some
you know boxer or something I hope that
was said like in some book
yeah it's not it's not a boxer don't
worry uh okay although that was gonna be
a that'd be a sweet thing though if uh a
boxer said it
well sometimes athletes quote
some philosophical spots and then if
I've never heard it I'm like I don't
think he said that I don't think
not sure he came up with that Knight D6
though it's some still some chances
Maybe
but Queen C2 Queen A2
and this sucks worrisome because Quincy
2 the King goes up to H3 oh I never
answered your question by the way it's
Voltaire but um or at least that's who
it's attributed to probably stole it
from somebody who doesn't get credit but
um
fall Voltaire just had a friend like a
drinking some alcohol in the 17th
century and I don't know when Hotel was
alive I'm very sorry 18 well I think
18th century is probably one of I don't
know someone can Google this I'm not
gonna do it all right
96.
can't take anything Rook F7 Bishop D6
good luck
whoa
right this looks like a hanging Pond but
Rook F7 Bishop D6 as pointed out and
this Rook is under attack so you can't
take with the Knight
can you move the bishop because Queen
takes up seven is there oh
and where are you moving where do you
move the bishop Bishop takes H6
no because then Queen seeds oh
he makes a move that's just losing
Knight F4 Queen C6 Knight F4 Bishop D6
Queen C6 Knight F4 Queen C6 and then I
don't know
yeah it feels like it feels like there's
something like that as you're saying
I don't know exactly where it is but it
or maybe just Queen C2
Queen C2 also looks great
Queen C2 King H3
where is the game Ender there
that's the question
I'm perplexed myself
well
no that also doesn't work it's very easy
to look at the eval bar oh apparently
you didn't even find it yeah but this I
think is sufficient you were yeah and
she just trade everything and play Queen
C6
this is happening take F4 Queen C6 check
the Queens immediately come off D6 Falls
and hikar just needs to draw he doesn't
need to win this game nope
it doesn't need to win
and you know who's not going to win this
game is linear Dominguez because Rook F6
Rook F5 might even hold the Pawns
there's King E4 oh that is a that's a
good move that's it I think Hikaru just
played like
all the best moves in this game went his
position got unpleasant it's just unreal
just incredible stuff what more can you
even when even when it seems like he's
in trouble right he just finds every
single accurate defensive move and
Hikaru Nakamura
unless something really tragic happens
he is going to make his way to Toronto
Canada in the first week of November and
he will play for a shot at 200
000 dollars
this is everything that Hikaru has to
offer as a chess player super sharp
calculation skills solid time management
defensive Brilliance and it was all on
display today Lanier really felt like he
brought his A-game for about 90 of the
action today and Hikaru brought it for
100 maybe 99 if you want to argue you
cannot be fully perfect in chess but he
was incredible and of course I'm sure
Hikaru would make some adjustments but
Robert I think really what this will
come down to is the question of was
Lanier too passive at critical moments
or was Hikaru just unbeatable
hey Carl when he plays like this there
are maybe two people in the world who
are going to beat him in a match and
right now Hikaru Nakamura he's rising to
the occasion he struggled in The Opening
match against Grand Master Vasquez
against Navara he looked very good but
he has looked phenomenal here winning
game one after extensive preparation
from Dominguez looked like it should be
a level game but he pressed and pressed
in an extra Pawn led to a victory and
then after that it's been a steady
Nakamura through and through here in
game four he doesn't even need to win
he's about to win and he is going to
make his way through to the final eight
and Hikaru Nakamura is just an absolute
Beast yeah apparently that wasn't given
the blessing somehow apparently it's
some sort of draw now
rookie seven and then the King has to oh
he's mad he's Maddie messed it up he
wanted to win but he blundered into a
check check situation now if he goes in
front of his Rook there's C7 uh so yeah
he kind of smiled but luckily it was
already in the bag and yeah Lanier is
intent on not making the drawk he still
wants to win so
this is very common in musculine
situations right and for a moment it was
oh no his online rapid rating but Hikaru
is going to uh take this one home he has
three different past pawns Rooks can't
really handle them because he just start
pushing but hikara just wants to make a
draw he doesn't care about winning this
game he just draw locks up the match
his plane ticket is booked well not yet
but it will be and he will head on over
to Toronto Canada after going to
Reykjavik Iceland for the official
random Championship I know that's so
wild he's gonna have to fly from from
Reykjavik to Toronto it's gonna be and
okay so this is where's the repetition
they're repeated 10 times
congratulations to Hikaru Nakamura on a
very convincing round of 16 matchup
versus linear Dominguez and he is our
final qualifier of the day to the round
of eight in Toronto
foreign
wow Hikaru Nakamura insanely impressive
performance of him and you know slow
clap golf clap for Leno Dominguez who is
eliminated from the 2022 cgc but he
earns 15
000 in a two impressive matchups so we
see the scores on the screen in front of
us here we have a win for Hikaru is
actually three to one uh sorry two and a
half one and a half it doesn't matter
what the final score is he won the match
uh but he is the winner as is Dimitri on
draken
yeah if you asked me before today's
matchups whether I thought that
uh Hikaru would win or Lanier would win
I would I would say hikara was the
favorite the biggest shock of the day
was not the fact that Dimitri and Drake
and won but it was in the way that he
did it and it was honestly also a
colossal defensive effort from him and I
think what we're realizing as players
are saying goodbye to the rest of the
field and staying you know staying home
I want to say going home but staying
home really for a lot of these matchups
it's not just about how you start these
games and how you find yourself in the
middle it's really that you have to be
unbeatable at multiple critical moments
and on dragon and Hikaru today showed
that they are and playing like that I
don't exactly know what the seating is
in Toronto I don't know exactly who
plays who on the first day or the second
day but it's going to be amazing to see
all of these best players emerge and
ultimately Clash against each other
and we can see how Dimitri on Drake and
made his way through to the round of
eight he first took down Aram hakobian
he then beat gotta komski and then
finally last but certainly not least in
this group he beats Fabiano caruana so
Dimitri on draken he will square up I
believe against Wesley so but Hikaru
Nakamura he also earned his way through
to Toronto out of group a he first beat
Rodrigo Vasquez then David Navarra and
then lenier the Ming is in a very
impressive performance today
yeah got absolutely nothing more I can
add to that it was
sort of everything that that we were
built for and everything that we had
prepared for in a matchup between Hikaru
and Lanier Lanier came out guns blazing
in many of these games he had some
really really nice positions but
like I said you have to play moves you
can't just get there and say look what I
look look what I have here this is my
presentation please make a judgment on
it you actually have to play moves and
Hikaru forces you to make the Right
Moves not just once not just twice but
the entire game and you saw in that last
game that he is capable of playing 15
best defensive moves in a row how do you
beat a guy like that I don't know don't
ask me don't ask Robert don't ask linear
Dominguez because nobody has been able
to figure it out and I still think that
he is a number one or number two
favorite in Toronto and he was fully
focused he let his moves do the talking
and well we're gonna have a chance to
catch up with him when we come back from
this short break we will have a car in
Nakamura for an interview so stay tuned
here at the 2022 chess.com Global
Championship presented by Brave
[Music]
foreign
Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru congrats on a
great match how does it feel to book
your ticket to Toronto
yeah I mean it's it's nice to uh to win
the patch I I don't know if I
necessarily played great chess uh but
fortunately I was able to keep it
together when there was when there's a
lot of pressure and yeah it's just it's
great it's great to win a match
yeah my question was going to be in that
last game we realized 22 moves into it
Hikaru that this the 19 moves that had
been played were the same so
is that a deliberate attempt and then it
maybe goes slightly awry or how like how
does that happen how do you go into the
same 19 or 20 moves just what what are
the feelings like especially as the game
is developing
yeah I mean I basically forgot to look
at the line I simply forgot but Lenny I
played this against me and um in St
Louis I just I completely forgot that
that he had done it so I didn't look at
the line and I mean I I knew there was
another line that I was intending to
play but I figured uh you know at the
end of the day that he would have to
prove something and I think he actually
did prove something I thought H4 what he
did was great I suspect for a computer
it was completely winning
um but I think maybe he was a little bit
too slow this G3 F4 I think if you've
gone F4 right away or maybe some A6 I
mean I feel like there's probably some
computer line where it's very close to
winning for white uh but at the end of
the day we're only humans if you can't
prep to move 40 I mean you have to find
the moves then uh you know we're not
3800 so Lenny air couldn't find the move
well in general in this match hikara
felt like you were going down on the
clock early out of the opening stage not
something we see every day from you so I
guess what does that indicate in terms
of how seriously you were taking the
match and how strong of a player linear
is and what a tough opponent he is for
you well I mean the first thing is the
first game there's no there's no reason
not to go down on the clocks I'm up a
pawn like in the worst case I'll always
be able to bail and make a draw so
there's no reason not to use that time
um since I'm the one who is extra Pawn
in the second second game I've already
that was the the Berlin game yeah I was
just trying to remember the what I
prepared for the candidates uh I mean I
know there are a couple lines with this
bishop B2 or Bishop E5 and I'm just
making sure that I didn't mess up the
move forward and I think what I did was
correct with Bishop E5 I know there's
another one where you take on B2 then
you go back to E5 but I think what I did
was correct and um uh it was another
position that once it simplified it was
it was very uh it was very simple to
play so I I think in terms of first
against that was fine in terms of third
game honestly uh maybe maybe this will
sound a little bit little little bit
arrogant but if I if I hadn't need if I
hadn't started a feeling I need to use
the restroom somewhere around like move
10 I think I probably would have won
this game and we wouldn't have had a
fourth game honestly because uh when I
played this ah4 move for some reason I I
was expecting G4 and then I was gonna go
Bishop D6 but I can simply play the
other order with Bishop D6 96 takes
Queen d6h4 G4 G3 and I'm just a little
bit better and it's very easy to play so
um yeah it happens and then fourth game
obviously was was very choppy but I
think uh I just made better decisions in
the critical moments
that was going to be part of my question
is one of the things Robert and I said
today and one of the things that
obviously gets said about this highest
Echelon like that you bring when you
place you know especially in these in
these rapid and Blitz events is uh
defensive uh just ability to buckle down
play some rerouting moves play quickly
not overthink the position do you think
that is the single most important skill
to make it to a final eight for example
in out of 64 players is that really what
it comes down to everybody has
preparation everybody's good tactically
but when it comes down to playing some
of these unpleasant positions it seemed
like you were just unbeatable today the
position could have been slightly worse
could have been much maybe much better
for Lanier but he wasn't just going to
beat you at all
I mean I think it highlights the
difference between classical chess and
then rapid and Blitz I mean there's a
reason when you play classical chess
that you actually spend like four or
five hours looking at stuff before a
game as opposed to Rapid and Blitz
because if I played the way that I
played today uh In classical I think I
would have lost the last game
specifically
um so that that does highlight a big
difference I mean I I think ultimately
yeah it comes down to the critical
moments when you're playing rapid and
Blitz who who makes less blunders but
also considering that I knew I was worse
I I started trying to just play nepo
style and just play Fast
um unfortunately I think my moves for
the most part were pretty good and again
as they start getting lower and lower it
just became too difficult uh to play
with no time on the clock and also I
mean when you're playing with a two
second increment I mean you do have an
increment but that increment really goes
goes by quickly so if you get to like 30
seconds it is almost like
you can make a couple of quick moves and
just like that you have 30 seconds but
with a two second increment it's it's
very tough and um yeah I again I thought
I made good decisions when I was under
pressure for the most part and it's just
I'm very happy
yeah nicaro you obviously are world
renowned streamer and you know of course
beloved now you're chess is taking you
over the board again you're going to uh
Iceland at the end of October then to
Canada at the first week of November
does that excite you to be playing you
know in more and more over the board
events in addition to your streaming
it's it's fun to play chess let's let's
leave it at that but I will say
um I actually really excited to go to
Iceland I haven't been there in I think
18 years so I I am really excited to go
to Reykjavik that should be it should be
a lot of fun how I do that and then go
to Toronto I mean I'll figure all that
out later but it is great because at the
end of the day I feel like with both
both the um the 960 but then also this
event really the main goal was make it
to the make it to the end like at this
point like sure I can lose the next
match and I I won't I won't really care
I just wanted to make sure that I get to
get to you know go and play play chess
so it's all good
yeah do you prefer over the board do you
prefer fully online or do you prefer
traveling to a location and playing on a
computer in front of another guy
physically
I mean I
act I have to say I don't know what the
format is I've heard both like I I think
I heard from Fabiano that we're playing
on computer screens I think I heard from
Leonards or test however pronounce his
name that we're playing on dgt board so
I really don't have any idea what's
going on exactly
um so I'll just I'll just see see how it
goes but I do think that um after long
periods of time it is a little bit odd
play on board it definitely felt it when
I played in St Louis in the in the rapid
and Blitz uh maybe it's about a month
ago now it seemed a little bit odd
playing over the board where it wasn't
Blitz just so I think I think it just it
depends on what I've been playing a lot
of recently
yeah no I I mean hey Cara your schedule
always is busy you're seemingly mopping
up events left and right including a
double title Tuesday Victory so uh you
know always great to see you
participating and this was a tremendous
match of me we heard from you saying uh
you could have done a few things better
here and there but ultimately you are
the person moving through and it was a
great showing so congratulations zakara
thank you guys
thank you so much
yes all right
well Hikaru Nakamura has made his way
through against lenier Dominguez we'll
show you the bracket once more he takes
down Rodrigo Vasquez David Navara and
lenier Dominguez of Levy he's always a
Powerhouse but Hikaru just showed his
best chess when he needed it today
yeah I like how he and Lanier are the
same seed I know they became the same
person toward the end uh and then they
emerged you know it's like uh two versus
two so only number one emerges
um listen hikara was the favorite in
this matchup just like in tennis we have
certain uh areas where an individual is
kind of uh
predicted to be the the winner and he
did his job he took care of business
there was UPS there was Downs he was
dominance in some matches and this match
was super super close but now we get to
see him in Toronto that's really the Big
Show
for sure and since we're speaking of uh
you know these great matches we also saw
uh Dimitri on draken take down Fabiano
caruana so as we dive a little bit more
into that match uh let's take a closer
look because it's time for a new segment
we like to call the brave move of the
day in which we highlight a key move or
set a move to decide the outcome of the
match between andrekin and carwana and
it was a draw in game one but Levy here
in game two we can see that both players
down under 10 seconds carwana makes the
move King to G6 and on draken has his
eyes on the prize here with no time of
the clock
yeah he uncorks Bishop to E4 which
overloads the light squared Bishop from
the defense of the promotion uh and the
defense of the E4 square if you take the
bishop obviously white is promoting if
you do not which ultimately happened in
the game the bishop is unable to deal
with the consequences of promotion and
Dimitri went on to win and this was this
was really the beginning of the end for
Fabiano You could argue that it was the
beginning of the end not just in this
game of the entire match but I don't
know I don't know if Bishop B4 was the
brave move of there Fabiano's King G6
was a little too brave but yes Bishop E4
sealed the deal not just in this game
but it really felt overall in Mr
fairchess on YouTube or Dimitri on
draken as he goes by uh punch this
ticket to Toronto by winning this game
and then the next one
yeah it certainly was the critical
moment because it allowed him to take a
lead and he did not relinquish that lead
and that's our brave move the day
remember it's time to make your move
from chrome to Brave try it now at
brave.com
chess so Levy we have two players making
their way through to Toronto in addition
to the two that we saw yesterday so we
know Hikaru Nakamura is up top away the
winner of Duda and Serana Wesley so will
take on Dimitri on draken the vanarone
will take on the winner of dingley Ren
and nihal sarin and then we have the
upper right hand side I mean no one is
made it through to the round of eight
from those two groups no that's sort of
like a foreign land to me as we see nepo
with rajabov that of course is a is also
another one and two matchup we've had
three of those the strangest matchup
gotta be here I've got no idea what to
expect Geary has been seemingly like it
like like in The Matrix just dodging
everything and just just being
incredible and uh his match up against
Roundup really made me think that he is
in Peak form in this event it wasn't
even close but how is he going to fare
against the man that has taken down a
five-time world champion as well as uh
the world uh rapid Champion I don't know
I really don't know it seems like any
time pankrative sits down to play he you
gotta maybe look at him as a potential
favorite in a matchup we'll see what
Geary comes with and how his prep is and
I don't know that one is the most the
one that's up in the air the most for me
yeah he started the event as one of
those kind of anonymous type of 2650
players but Pavo pancreatov he's a name
that people will remember after he beat
Vichy and nordybeck but we have these
matches on Wednesday October 5th that is
two days from now 9 A.M Pacific Time
Mark these down your calendars will
Anish Geary and John schizoph Duda the
number one seeds in their group well
they make it through or will the
upstarts in Pablo pankratov and Alexi
serrana will they continue their upset
streaks and make their ticket to Canada
and face off against the other Elite
player so Levy I mean it's been a
fantastic show I mean really some great
matchups and not only do we have the two
coming up on this coming Wednesday we
have two more the following Wednesday so
the round of 16 continues it is all
exciting oh it's super exciting it's a
shame we have to wait a little bit
longer for uh for these players but
listen people have commitments they have
to play in tournaments and while the
chess.com Global Championship brought to
you by Brave is quite an exciting event
to play over the board still for many of
the of these players takes precedence
but um yeah I'm super pumped for those
matchups I'm super pumped for nepo and
rajaba for dingly Ren and nihal sarin
Robert as always this was a pleasure and
I don't know what your thoughts are on
the upcoming matchups but I have been
more than satisfied and I am eagerly
looking forward to the remaining
matchups in round of 16 but also now
finding out who's going to play who in
Toronto yeah it's going to be an
interesting Wednesday or I should say
Wednesdays because our next two
Wednesdays will be jam-packed with
action here at the chess.com a global
Championship presented by Brave and well
before we sign off we do want to give
one last major shout out to our uh
presenting sponsor our friends at Brave
they will stick with us through Toronto
for the entirety of the cgc so thank you
so much uh for all of that but we are
going to sign off for now it is hikar
nakaburra it is Dimitri on draken they
will be joined by four more players in
the next two Wednesdays and of course
Wesley so levonne aronian and they made
their way through yesterday so now we
say goodbye see you Wednesday for more
from the chess.com Global Championship
presented by Brave
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]